[Music]
all right people this is it I feel like
this is a lifetime coming we are gonna
be deleting our patreon page during this
live stream for those of you that don't
know patreon has been the number one
source of funding for us since we went
independent back in June of 2016 that's
when I started my independent production
company that's when we fully took the
reins of this company and this show I
have no boss I am my boss I guess I am
the boss around here for better or worse
we've built a great little production
company we've got full timers we've got
part-timer as we pay for everyone's
insurance and dental and blah blah blah
we treat all of our employees great
I think we've built a really great show
here I think fans funding was the key to
making this thing truly successful the
fact that I can make whatever decision I
think is right for the show and the
business the fact that I've been able to
take sort of my my small government
principles and my my refound let's say
belief in in capitalism and business and
apply it to the things that I'm doing
behind the scenes as well as the issues
that I'm talking about on-air in front
of you guys
the last couple years have just been
amazing we show is just absolutely blown
up we're about to cross a million
subscribers on YouTube despite often
people being unsubscribed from the
YouTube channel the audio podcast is
basically bigger than the YouTube
channel at this point I think the things
that we've been talking about over the
last couple years have been incredibly
relevant and seemingly every day now
become more relevant I mean even the
fact that this is all going down on
patreon related to freedom of speech and
it was because of them kicking off carl
benjamin sargon of akkad who's been in
this very studio that we built and i
bought this house because of patreon or
because of in large part because of the
donations you guys have been making on
patreon over the last couple of years it
seems so fitting that we're gonna
finally do this so I know there's a lot
of eyeballs on this and I know there's a
lot of eyeballs and the media on this I
know there are employees at patreon
watching this right now how are you guys
I know there's big shots at Google and
Facebook watching and the rest of it and
I think that
look Sam Harris left patreon because of
this Jordan is deleting Jordan Peterson
is deleting his patreon account today he
may have done it already he's in
Switzerland right now we spoke on the
phone briefly we were gonna possibly
Skype him in on this I don't think it's
gonna happen cuz it's like 3:00 in the
morning there but who knows maybe some
surprises will happen over the course of
the next two hours but this seems like
just the next obvious step in everything
that's been going on here I just think
that at some point us the people have to
push back against these tech companies
you can't keep infringing on freedom of
expression yes they can do whatever they
want as private companies and there's
some issue whether these platforms are
now becoming the true public space of
the future and does that have what's the
relationship between that entity as a
platform that we can all communicate on
and the government we can discuss that
till the the nth degree
I am trying to apply the same principles
that I apply consistently to everything
else here I didn't ask the government to
come in and demand but sargon of akkad
stay on patreon or on Twitter or
anywhere else I didn't ask the
government to get involved and stop this
person from getting banned or that
person from getting banned i think these
bannings are a problem you guys know my
policy on gatekeeping I'd rather much
wider gates generally speaking as long
as people are following the laws of the
United States and we don't have hate
speech laws and people are allowed to
say mean things and it's scary sometimes
but I would much rather have that than
have all sorts of voices who are a
little outside of mainstream be shut
down
especially because in these days it's
not just the really bad voices that that
maybe are should be ignored perhaps it's
that it's coming for sort of everybody
so I'm gonna discuss a whole bunch of
things here we are gonna be deleting the
patreon page live so Erin can you throw
to the live shot of the computer that is
right here right now despite for the
last month me emailing all my patrons
doing live streams tweeting the hell out
of this thing posting it on Facebook
posting it on Instagram and God knows
what else I've been doing as you can see
right now right now we've got almost
1,800 patrons that still remain in there
for about $10,000 a month now I don't
think all right iron you come back to me
for a second I don't think a normal
person running a business would say oh
can I take what was when we started this
thing about a month ago when we started
announcing we were gonna leave or at
least when the when the carl benjamin
thing popped i don't think a normal
businessman is like oh can i just get
rid of 70% of my company's revenue and
we'll see what happens but i just felt
like it was just enough and i had faith
that you guys were gonna come with me on
this adventure so i am thrilled to say
that we have done really nicely we
haven't made up all the patreon money
but we've done really really nicely at
dave rubin comm / donate so we are gonna
use this livestream for one more round
of fundraising to really just blow that
thing up so it's dave rubin comm /
donate if you donate while i'm live
right now for five dollars and above i'm
gonna give you a live shoutout and I've
got a trusty iPad here and a team of
dedicated professionals in the in the
control room over there if you donate
via PayPal be a stripe whatever it is at
Dave Rubin commissary Snowden I'm gonna
give you a live shoutout if you donate
$25 or more per month you're gonna get
the Reuben reports select shirt now this
is the select shirt that are only our
patrons at certain levels we're getting
these will never be printed again we've
got a couple boxes in the left because
they were printed for patreon only
obviously we're never gonna print them
again
so these are the last couple that we've
got left I think we've got about a
hundred of them left let's see if we can
move some of these you will get one of
these you can you make the donation then
you send us your size we've got your
email we'll take good care eeeh and if
you donate 50 or more monthly I'm gonna
sign a Reuben report official mug that
will never be printed again either
because it's the select member mug I'm
gonna sign that for you right here live
on air and we're gonna send it to you
and you guys will ensure that the show
remains completely independent and and
as I said I've had a whole bunch of
offers from networks some that I would
consider working with I've had all sorts
of offers to do more ads on the show I
have had every which way that you can
think of funding something I've had
offers we've had other people offer us
big money I like doing it this way I
think it's great I'm psyched I'm happy
I'm content I want to keep growing
there's so many good things happening
over the course of the next year
in terms of we're continuing the tour
with jordan peterson in may and june
we're gonna hit all sorts of countries
in europe and do that again in february
for a couple weeks I'll be in Australia
we're bouncing all over the all over the
country in April we're considering I
have an offer to do a full month of
Rubin reports on the road all over the
United States I have to make sure that I
actually can do it because the other
thing is that I'm writing a book right
now which I've been writing forever and
my due date have the book done is August
1st so I got I got a lot going on and
I'm also supposed to do a show and I've
been doing stand-up again and all that
good stuff so there's a lot happening
here but I want to keep this momentum
going also the key to this whole thing
is that Jordan and I also are working on
a new platform so there's a limit to the
amount that I can talk about this
specifically for legal reasons and and I
can't give away all the secrets and the
keys to the kingdom just yet we're
working on another platform there are
huge huge questions related to how do we
want this platform to function and
should this be all you know should we be
monetized through crypto should we be
doing torrent video streaming and how do
we fully protect it so that not so that
we can't we don't have to worry about
payment processors we don't have to
worry about tech companies taking us
down and all of those things as crazy as
that is right all I'm doing here is
exercising free speech I like
interviewing people and and enjoy having
good conversation and all that stuff but
we do have to think about all these
things so Jordan and I are working on
that there is a company formed with so
there's all sorts of legal things that
have to be done within the rest of that
we are working about on that this what
I'm doing today is just step one of all
of that so step one for me was let's get
off patreon and let's move everybody so
that we can fund everybody on our site
whatever we do after this by the way if
you're if you're gonna jump over to Dave
Rubin comm slash donate and you do the
monthly credit card thing over there or
PayPal
we're gonna be able to fold that into
the new thing because we don't want
people to have to sign up for resilient
things and cancel the zillion things and
all that because as you can see by the
two thousand people that haven't
cancelled patreon yet people forget to
do things right so it's like I could
just not delete patreon right now and
just keep cashing in on these people but
I'm obviously not gonna do that so okay
here we go oh by the way so I'm gonna be
answering questions so you can answer
questions you can ask questions in super
I'm happy to take some questions there
I'm obviously going to be given some
prime real estate right now two people
that are the current patrons who are
asking questions and I just want to say
beyond anything else and then I'll tell
you some other fun stuff
I am beyond beyond beyond humbled and
honored and I I'm a better person
because of this whole adventure it I
can't describe to you what it is like to
have people all over the world just
believe in you doing something and I'm
just doing what I think is right that
really is it I'm some guy doing what I
think is right it's not any more magical
than that and for whatever reason we
live in a weird time especially in the
West or especially let's say in the
United States where we have we are in
the freest country in the history of the
world right now
this evil patriarchy that we live in is
the freest place ever and people are
afraid to say what they think they're
afraid to stand up and and fight for
what they believe in and and all this
stuff and I just I don't know what's
wrong with me but I just can't not do it
so so here I am um I'm just drawing a
line in the sand and I'm doing what I
think is right and I'm and I'm reaping
the rewards for it and I'm incredibly
humbled by that so I thank you guys
truly so again okay just one more one
more
reset on the radio here if you if you
donate five dollars and above during
this livestream I'm gonna give you a
live shoutout 25 bucks or above monthly
you're getting the reuben report shirt
that will never be printed again people
the select member shirt that'll never be
printed again fifty dollars or above
you're gonna get the shirt and you're
gonna get the mug and I'm gonna sign the
mug for you right here I've got a trusty
sharpie okay
and now just to sweeten the deal I sent
out one of the Reuben report team
members to pick up an unopened bottle of
patron okay we just picked this thing up
I am opening it for the first time and I
don't know exactly what we're gonna do
with this when we originally launched on
patreon back in 2016 we were trying to
figure out fun ways to raise funds and
one of the things I did was I think for
every thousand bucks we raised during a
live stream I did a shot and if I'm not
mistaken within like an hour and a half
I had done like five shots I was wasted
I think I do
I'm like seven shots it was not pretty
it was not good and I'm older now and
I'm wiser and I don't think I can do
that level but I've got an unopened
bottle of patron as you can see here
Aaron go to the other screen so I can
show them this thing is unaltered
untouched okay and and I've got a trusty
shot glass this shot glass by the way
you can't see anything on it right now
unfortunately I got this at Universal
Studios it used to have a Decepticon
logo on it which I really loved and I
don't know what happened to the
Decepticon logo but I will do a shot in
honor of Soundwave so I don't know
exactly what I'm gonna make the the the
marks for when I'm gonna do shots but
impress me you know dude throw out
something good on just super chat we are
we're trying to raise some funds here
and then we're gonna delete this thing
at the end and and I hear I haven't I'm
gonna have some chili for dinner so okay
so let me ask some questions Oh a couple
shoutouts quick to Devon Andrew Eric
Jeff and Travis thank you guys okay on
super chat go Reuben go I'll do it
alright thank you good luck Dave and
team wishing you the best Dave here's to
the future we're here to support you
CBD American shaman of San Antonio I do
you know every now and again I'll do a
little a little if I got like an ache or
something I think I mentioned this the
other day take a little CBD cream and I
do like the CBD Dave thanks for all the
great videos I'm a size large I'll
debate tomorrow about the government
shut I mean a debate tomorrow about the
government shutdown wish me luck good
luck to you let's see for free speech
what is your opinion on The Daily wire
and do you wish to join well first off I
think the Daily wires doing great stuff
I obviously have some disagreements with
the Conservatives on a couple of
different things I have some
disagreements with men I've discussed
those disagreements right here related
to to some gay issues and to abortion
and to death penalty and a bunch of
other things but I think Ben is a decent
guy and I think despite our differences
we want to live in the same country
together we've had a good time on stage
together last month at one of the jordan
peterson events here in l.a I brought
Ben out on stage the crowd went bananas
he brought me you know there we have
this gay cake debate so he brought me a
little cupcake everyone went crazy and
it was just wonderful thousands of
people screaming and it's like you know
then I look on Twitter and it's like the
usuals the tolerant progressives oh look
at the homophobe
the gay guy onstage together it's like
grow up you children what planet do you
want to live on okay so go Ruben go we
did that one hey Dave I just want to say
thank you for standing on principle no
matter the cost you've inspired my own
channel from the start and I'm grateful
that's awesome I want a zillion people
to do this I don't need to you know I'm
doing interviews a lot of people do
interviews but it's like more and more
and more let's get a little braver here
let's keep telling people what we think
we got a lot of bad people right now
that are willing to shout everybody down
and D platform everybody and and scream
you're racist and you're a bigot and all
this other nonsense they're very brave
right now and I see a lot of good people
that are not brave and and that's part
of the the problem at the moment and
we're gonna fix that so reminder we're
just raising some funds right now here
you know what if I'll do a shot for Matt
at the net when we hit 500 bucks on
super chat I'll do a shot how about
something like that or you know let's
get we really want to get people over to
today Ruben calm / donate though because
we're trying to we just want to make
sure we have a good monthly budget so we
can grow the show we can continue to do
the things that we're doing and all that
so the more of you that jump over there
the better guys if we're getting
shoutouts and mugs I'm not seeing it on
here so maybe we're not live on here I'm
not sure if anything's not being edited
so I like so let me know about that guys
on patreon I'm behind free speech and
you Dave and Jordan thank you for all
your hard work on behalf of free people
everywhere on my way over to Dave's news
site to donate there in place a patreon
much love and success to you both in
2019 thank you very much
another one on patreon out on patreon on
as a direct owner thanks a lot you know
the other part of this is you know
nobody from patreon has reached out to
me jack conte who sat in that chair and
said that you all you wouldn't get
kicked off patreon for speech you would
only get kicked off for manifest
observable behavior which is a term that
I think he made up which has the acronym
mob mo be manifest observable behavior
so only a mob could kick you off because
you can't make [ __ ] up I mean that's
completely bananas I just realized that
I just don't trust them I and it's like
look do I trust Google do I trust
YouTube do we trust any of these things
not really but I think that the
experiment of patreon was sort of small
enough that I want
to make a move on this and as I've said
in some of the other lives communes look
I have friends and people that I have
nothing but total respect for like Brett
Weinstein and Colin Moriarty
who are staying on patreon right now and
maybe they'll be able to fight on the
inside and get them to change their
Terms of Service
even though they didn't even follow
their own Terms of Service because in
the patreon Terms of Service they said
these are the things you're not allowed
to say on our platform
Carl Benjamin did not say the n-word on
their platform he said it he didn't even
say it on his own YouTube channel he
said it on someone else's YouTube
channel 10 months ago and he didn't even
use the n-word as a racially pejorative
term he used it because he was using the
language perhaps slightly sloppily of
the alt-right against them that's the
point this guy debates all right people
he is not a racist and I also think it's
sort of fitting that that this all sort
of boils down to two Carl not to make it
too much about him but when I was having
my wake up when I was a full-on lefty
and I was on TYT and I don't know I
guess I had a lobotomy you're saying
when I was part of that thing when I
started waking up to what was going on
related to free speech and the
authoritarianism that had permeated
throughout the left and and this this
this really awful social justice monster
that I think now everybody obviously
sees and I guess I happen to be one of
the first people that was seeing it when
when I started talking about everybody
said you got to talk to Carl Benjamin
you got to talk to this guy sargon of
akkad so it seems sort of fitting that
the first guy that I talked to online
about all this was the one who got
booted that's now causing me to leave
this and we're just taking control of
our destiny and all that good stuff
shoutouts to Kyle - Joshua - Nolan -
Noah and - Colin thank you one small
step for intellectuals one giant leap
for the intellectual dark web hashtag
shots of freedom watched you with Jordan
at the Tabernacle here in Atlanta you
guys were awesome keep it up love you
buddy that was actually one of my
favorite shows because it was Jordans
birthday and the crowd was just
fantastic people spontaneously sung
happy birthday to him we brought him out
you know he won't eat cake so we brought
him out a raw steak with the with the
candle in it it was it was just a blast
though and the crowd was just great
Atlanta's just a great city way to stand
up for your principles thank you thanks
for standing up for Liberty Dave looks
or to seeing you and Jordan in New
Zealand I'm not gonna be in New Zealand
I can't do the New Zealand leg I'm gonna
leave Australia a little bit early I got
one week of the year my family everybody
folks brother sister nieces nephews
everybody we all get together for one
week in an undisclosed location and
that's the one week we do it and and for
all the goodness that's going on and
after as much as I would love to be in
New Zealand I need some of that good New
Zealand lamb I'm not gonna be I'm not
gonna be there for that I'm sorry about
that but I promise I will get back there
at some point trust me it sucks there
it's one of the places that I haven't
been that I would love to get to and I
will get there at some point I promise
you that shout out to Patrick and
reminder guys you can get shirts
25 bucks monthly you're getting a shirt
a Reuben report shirt
it is a select member shirt by the way
that will never be printed again 50
bucks I'm signed in mugs people don't
make me leave these mugs in this room I
got to get rid of I got to move product
you know what I'm saying let's see why
have you not had Michael McCord or
McWhorter or Glenn Lowry on the show I
don't know why it's happened I think
we've been in touch with Lowry at least
let me let me look into that thanks for
standing up for free speech good luck
Dave okay so here we go I'm going to
first I'm going to open up the patron so
make me an offer I can't refuse I mean
that's what I'm saying people go over to
Dave Rubin dot-com sesh know and it make
me an offer I can't refuse I'll do a
shot at patron in honor of leaving
patreon foria by the way I'm having a
crazy day over here not only just with
the energy around this thing but I shot
three shows already today which were
which were really something I don't even
want to give everything away so we've
got a great show tomorrow that I taped
the first thing this morning I'll leave
it up to mystery at the moment but I'd
really tape three great shows today and
all right so I am opening this bad boy
it is now open
there we go smells like tequila oh man I
don't have any I don't have any lime or
salt or anything we'll figure that out
hey Dave this is a very brave move on
your part kudos have you heard about the
SJW nonsense
I don't know I don't even care about
those guys does it really just honestly
doesn't matter
viva la free speech good luck Dave [ __ ]
you patreon alright I'm reading these
live take a shot for me keep up the
amazing work
good luck Dave thanks for standing up to
free speech shout out to Carlos and to
John and to Michael alright okay so
here's what we're do I will pour a first
shot just to to get this thing going
here this is what the Internet's really
about people about people getting drunk
on YouTube apparently I guess that's a
big thing right don't people get drunk
and cook or the rest of it so can't
people get drunk and do a little
fundraising okay let's see so we're
gonna do eet patreon I don't know how
long we're to do this I think we're
gonna probably go till about 7 o'clock
Pacific probably about two hours I'm
just shooting the [ __ ] with you guys I'm
happy to to answer any questions and and
just talk whatever and shout out to
Nathan shoutout to Kendra shout out to
Michael thank you guys and and then
after that so let me just plot out a
little bit of sort of the way I see the
future so look we're gonna move
everybody to my website we're read my
websites actually pretty cool if you
haven't been to Dave Rubin calm even if
you don't want to donate I think we've
done a nice job over there you can see
upcoming events that I have and and you
know the rest of it
we are completely redoing my website
though and we're gonna make it much more
of a destination so we're gonna be
hosting our own videos there making sure
that that nothing can be taken down
we're looking at all the pressure points
online of how you would take something
down how would you demonetized you stop
somebody from posting video we're taking
care of all of those things these are
all also obviously within the
discussions that I'm having with Jordan
about the upcoming platform there's also
a series of other things I don't want to
make this team like this is only Jordan
and I working on this many of the
players that you know whose names I need
not mention at the moment are working on
all sorts of different solutions to this
problem and who knows who knows what
will be the right solution to these
problems but I'm also very enthused that
I've mentioned this before I'm getting a
ton of people from big tech companies
from Google and Facebook and a whole
bunch of others that are reaching out to
me that are working at these companies
this ain't right what's going on here
and we've got to fight this monster so
I'm very enthused about that and we'll
see if we can grab some of these guys
all right guys I don't think that the
mugs line at the mug t-shirt line I
don't think is loading right now
shoutouts to William and to Jackson when
you come into New England Dave I don't
know that we have any New England plans
at the moment I will be I have a couple
Cali things coming up so I'm gonna be in
San Jose and San Diego and Riverside
California next week with Jordan
Peterson and then I will be at the
Irvine improv in Orange County on
January 30th doing stand-up I do about
an hour of stand-up I bring one of the
IDW guys onstage it's a it's an absolute
blast I was in Ontario California which
I didn't realize was a place and we had
a lot of people in Ontario Canada
because both RCA that I think showed up
to the Improv over there but we had rid
of just a freaking I just crushed it for
an hour it's it's stand-up like you've
never seen before I'm barely telling
jokes I go up there I have a good time
it's politically incorrect I get
everybody involved we do Q&A I mess
around with the crowd it's it's fun it's
fun so I hope you guys will come out to
that okay let's see speaking of drinking
will you have Michael malice on the show
again
or when his new book comes out is he an
alcoholic or something I don't see the
connection to drinking but I'd love to
have Michael malleus on again Michael is
a is a brilliant guy he's a really
brilliant political thinker if you
haven't seen my interview with him you
should check it out I consider him the
Willy Wonka of politics he's kind of
Willy Wonka watch the interview you'll
see it it's also how he dresses
but he's he's a great political thinker
he's more on sort of the ancap side of
things sort of like an extreme
libertarian view of freedom which I
certainly love exploring those ideas I
think he's just got good energy and he's
good
Patrick I'm signing your mug I guess the
mug thing just kicked in all right
Patrick I'm signing a mug for you
welcome on board we've got about 50 mugs
left we're moving mugs people Patrick
you're getting the first one there you
go my friend thank you very much
let's see Thank You mr. Rubin I
appreciate all your hard work and you've
truly opened my eyes to different points
and views try to get dr. Peterson to
come down to Louisiana I don't think we
did a show in Louisiana I'm pretty sure
that after we do these three in
California that that'll be it for this
year Jordans writing a new
book and I'm writing a book maybe Jordan
will be opening for me on my book tour
we shall see about that so there will be
more tours obviously in the United
States we're trying to think about some
other touring ideas with some of the IAW
crew as I mentioned I have this offer on
the table for all of April all over the
United States to take the Rubin report
on the road and do pretty big theaters
like thousand thousands of like 1500
seats per per venue so we're thinking
about I just got to figure out if I have
enough time to write so we're gonna
we're gonna work on that
shout outs to Torben and to Mike welcome
on board guys thank you Dave please try
to get damn crenshaw on your show he
would be an interesting guest in a
rising star I completely agree and I'm
happy to report because we drop in live
news on live streams that I've been in
touch with Dan he is the new congressman
down in Texas he is gonna come on the
show he's a fan of the show he's happy
to do it we're just trying to arrange it
during a trip that he has to LA and by
the way since I will have a freshman
like a freshman congressman like Dan
Crenshaw on the show I will gladly have
Alexandria Cortez or Omar Ilan or Laden
Omar whatever name is or tule bar any of
these people that want to come in I will
gladly talk to any of them dan is dan
has already offered to come on so
that'll be great how about a Reuben
Report app we're in discussions on many
fronts I have a proposal sitting in my
email from a company that does pretty
slick apps and we're trying to just
we're basically just trying to
streamline all of this I really think
that the internet is changing right in
front of us right now like we've had I
think we had like the first 10 years of
social media that were sort of the glory
years where everybody was meeting
everybody and people liked being on
Facebook and likes connecting with
people on Twitter and you could meet
heroes of yours or athletes that you
like or authors and people were
connecting and it was all great then in
the last couple years the internet
started eating itself in a way and the
trolls took over and the hate and all
that stuff now again I say this me
despite the fact that I would say 90%
despite I have an extremely dedicated
group of loser trolls that are always
following me and I just mute them who
cares but 90% of what I see online is
positive so I think most of its still
positive but I think that generally it's
just something to do with the human
condition people focus on the negative
more they focus on the positive so I
think people think it's all horrible
even though it really isn't that bad but
that's the other reason why being on the
tour has been so great because I get to
see actual people in real life and
they're often quite pleasant as opposed
to how they are online shout-out to
Shamari and to mark thank you guys
super chat I'm with your brother all
right right on and keep up the great
fight for free speech I have nothing
better to do I mean really I was
thinking about it the other day like how
it's kind of digging like some of this
can be a little bit annoying like I am
sort of spread thin in a certain way
like I'm trying to do my interview
tional I'm trying to do you stand up I
got a business to run like I'm on tour a
whole bunch of other things and now I'm
sort of like half leading a tech company
you know my weekends have just kind of
disappeared but it's like no what else
do I better do and it's it's more it's
more fun to be spread thin than when
you're just like you have nothing to do
so life's an adventure
I guess you guys are you guys are seeing
my adventure all right here's what we're
gonna do if we get a hundred bucks on on
super chat the next hundred bucks on
super chat I will take a shot of
petronia this is a big shot too
I should not have poured that that much
of it in there that was that was a
mistake you're the man Ruben thank you
very much appreciate that what the hell
are we doing here people I am deleting
patreon alive today Aaron let's go to
the the video there so I'm gonna I just
learned that you can refresh a page on
the computer there if you press command
R that's very fancy so I'm refreshing
the page I think I'm refreshing did i
refresh the page command R maybe all
right I'm gonna refresh the old way the
way I know how old-school I'm refreshing
the page how are we doing did we drop it
all so we still have 1777 people
donating nine thousand nine hundred
eleven dollars people please cancel stop
paying me there what are you doing I
don't know what else to tell you guys
please you've got to stop doing it
you're I appreciate the
stick-to-itiveness and the dedication
but I you know join me over at the
website David knock on a door
don't but let's get your patreon let's
save a couple bucks then for yourself ok
what else is going on here
ok this iPad is going a little slow
right now ok
next hundred bucks on super chat I'm
taking the shot so what else is
happening at the moment you know what
I'm gonna tell you who we who we
interviewed today because it was really
was really a really really interesting
day that I think is sort of sums up so
much of what's going on here and I think
why you guys why you guys dig this thing
so we started the day with dr. Everett
Piper who's the president of Oklahoma
Wesleyan University which is a small
College about 1,500 students he is a
staunch staunch defender of intellectual
freedom and he's written several books
on it and why we're coddling these young
people and why it's terrible he comes
from a it's a Christian University comes
from a Christian perspective and we
talked a lot about ethics and we talked
about living with honor and where the
rights come from and a lot of my
wheelhouse things but with a little bit
of a religious perspective that we've
done a little bit before fascinating guy
like I just one of the things that I
like most is when I get a guest who
really you can tell really knows their
ideas in and out and can tackle them in
all sorts of different ways I just love
that and he was truly a master of his
idea so we're posting that one tomorrow
we're doing it in one piece then we took
about a half hour break I had lunch had
a salad and then I interviewed Heather
McDonald from the Manhattan Institute
and I'm sure most of you know Heather
McDonald she's she's a really
fascinating public figure who's taken
some pretty politically incorrect
positions on welfare on black lives
matter on the me2 movement she writes
extensively about sort of third wave
feminism and how it's gone haywire and
the assault on men which is obviously
becoming more and more relevant did you
guys see this idiotic Gillette promo
that they put up yesterday it's just
embarrassing like this this need for
these companies to embrace social
justice in which is such a broad its
intellectual rot and these companies
just go for it hook line and sinker it's
just pathetic and awful let's see so so
I had Heather on a great discussion
unfortunately had to cut cut it
a quick because she was in a rush it's
we only did about 50 minutes or so and
then my third one was really interesting
conversation with a guy by the name of
tal Keenan and he is an American Israeli
who's written sort of a book about sort
of what he thinks the history of the
Jews or the future of the Jews is going
to be which I thought was sort of
interesting because we've done a lot
I've done more on especially on theology
and religion related to people when it's
come to Christianity we haven't done
that much on Judaism although I've had
rabbi won't be on a couple of times so
it's really just a really interesting
day and what was particularly
interesting about it was that my day
started talking to a guy who talks about
things from a Christian perspective
Heather
considers herself a secular conservative
which we talked about because people
don't think that that exists people seem
to think that to be a true conservative
you have to be religious well she makes
a great point that you do not in fact
then you'll hear more about that in the
interview and then it ended up talking
with somebody talking about the future
of Judaism so I thought wow this is what
I mean I want to talk about diversity
now they all happen to be white although
tall was was more brown I suppose but
this was diversity of thought and that
is the diversity of matter that matters
did you know that Jake John and Joe
three days in a row thank you guys okay
super ciao all right here we go
I'm a man of my word getting too old for
this 42 years old the 42 year olds do
shots is that a thing
well 42 year olds about oh and they
brought I've got an all-star team here
let me let me put this in front of the
computer for a second I've got let's put
that in front of the computer
I've got lime I've got salt oh god
that's the screenshot right there all
right I'm gonna do it all right up
another one take the shot all right here
we go
it's been a long time coming so a little
salt here we go got salt got tequila has
a little salt there's a little tequila
and you like lime I've always liked lime
I like sprite you're not supposed to
drink it I don't really drink it that
often sprite zero every now and again
although that'll kill you too but I do
like I like lemon-lime I like citrus
alright there you go so I hope you're
happy person who did that thank you very
much oh man I really haven't eaten today
I had a salad and I had two glasses of
bone broth this could be very messy
people what am i doing I'm deleting
patreon and taking shots of patron and
we're fundraising to keep the show fully
independent look I'm not gonna I don't
intend on doing fundraisers a lot
throughout the year we've done a nice
job we've transitioned a whole good
portion of people the business is going
to continue I promise you that we're
trying to just get to the same levels
that we were at before so so I don't
know my guys were saying we should be
trying to get to a specific number right
now or we should try to raise a certain
amount over the course of this two hours
or something like that I don't know well
we're just kind of playing it by ear and
then I will click on patreon and delete
it let me see did anyone drop aaron jump
back over there has anyone dropped I'm
trying to get these people to drop will
anyone drop did we yes we lost six
people that's what I'm talking about we
lost six people on patreon and we
dropped out I didn't see at the amount
of money on that but I am thrilled to
report people we are slowly dropping
patrons I can do this I can do a 24
hours stream and just wait for these be
some of these people could be dead for
all I know I don't know what's going on
here all right let's see time to take
the shot bring out Joe Rogan this is the
second person another shot no I think
what we're gonna have to do it will be
insane if I do this for every hundred
dollars that I do a shot I will be dead
before I'm able to press Delete on this
thing so I don't know the next shot has
to be 500 bucks that sounds crazy but
like I don't know it's the internet
people do crazy things but I want to do
a couple more we'll figure it out all
right
good luck brother patreon is a joke
anyway are you gonna ever get Noor
McDonald on yeah you know I I met norm
at a torah TV when I was over there with
Larry King and chatted with him in the
greenroom he said he'd do it we haven't
just been able to connect but I would
love to have him on sometimes people say
I sound like Norman Donald
I loved nor McDonald from Weekend Update
that was basically the last time I
watched Senate live does anyone watch
that crap anymore
I would love to know that in the
comments like does anyone watch
television anymore at all
I don't I watch on Sundays TV Land does
like a 8 a.m. to 4 p.m.
Golden Girls marathon and I kind of have
that on the background when I'm doing
other stuff in the house or just like
laying there with my dog or whatever but
I don't watch any television I haven't
watched well certainly Cable News or CNN
or anything like that and forever i
watch ancient aliens every now and again
you like the ancient aliens I like them
you know ancient alien theorists
theorized that canceling patreon and
going over to Dave Rubin calm slash
donate is one of the best things that
you can do ok good luck brother bow I
just did that one
Dave good luck with all the avenues
you're pursuing in 2019 what are your
predictions for Democratic candidates in
2020 will they fracture similar to the
Republicans in 2016 or the establishment
will the establishment back one
candidate I'm a little hesitant to say
this because I'm so frustrated with
what's happening on the left and the
Democrats and the progressives that I
don't want to tip them off to what I
think is going to happen but this is
just between me and you I think it's
gonna be a freakin bloodbath I think
that between Elizabeth Warren let's say
Bernie now they've got Tulsi Gabbard
there'll be a couple others on the
progressive side they'll throw you know
maybe a Cory Booker they'll throw in
someone who's a little more mainstream I
don't know exactly who that is because
there aren't really mainstream there
aren't really blue dog more centrist
Democrats anymore say a guy like Jim
Webb who was in one debate last time and
he looked like he was on the wrong stage
those people don't really exist so what
we think you're gonna happen is a
further splintering of the progressive
thing and the the Kamala Harris people
let's say are gonna call the Bernie
supporters racist cuz he's white and
they're gonna call them this because
they're this and you know and also
you're seeing these people try to
pretend that they're human I mean
watching you guys saw that video where
Elizabeth Warren drank the beer with her
husband and he just happened to be
standing there and they try to pretend
that their normal average people are
Kamala Harris did the video
with the music that she likes and
they're just robots
it's like Trump standing in the White
House surrounded by 10,000 burgers is
more of a human than what these people
are so in a weird way as much as I would
love and I want to be clear about this
as much as I would love for a decent
Democrat to return a good liberal a JFK
liberal a Daniel Patrick Moynihan and Ed
Koch an old-school liberal to return
from the ashes of this lunacy it's going
to get worse before it gets better and
that that person I don't know where the
hell that that person is it doesn't seem
to me that anyone can tell me who that
person is even the you know that person
who would that be maybe that's a Joe
Biden of 20 years ago who was more of a
mainstream Democrat but if the future of
of the Democrats is Joe Biden who's what
70 to 74 something like that then there
in a lot of trouble anyway and that is
not to say anything about the
Republicans I'm happy to answer
questions about the Republicans if you
got them but yes let's see okay let's
see shoutouts to Martha and to Nathan
let's see
super Chad subbed for $50 on your site
30 minutes ago long until you sign my
mug I'm not sure what you're saying
exactly there my guys are telling me the
mud thing but my iPads loading a little
slow so here was what I'm gonna do for
you imaginary person I believe you so
I'm signing a mug for you I'm gonna put
this one aside and let guys let's track
that super chat and figure out what's
going on here
Mahalo Dave for all things free speech
is lucky to have you as a close friend
keep up all of the awesome
Mahalo my friend
Viva free speech indeed hey Dave thanks
for all you do you should have Matt Fred
on to discuss his work on pornography
and its effect on culture you know a few
people have mentioned him before I
actually have his book here he talks a
lot about people's addiction to
pornography and a bunch of other things
I actually think it's pretty interesting
topic it just hasn't happened yet you
know I will do it we will make it happen
hang tight reminder guys I'm at Irvine
improv with an IDW guest on January 30th
they sold out so did one of the funny
things that my stand-up shows that we
didn't realize is that we do usually
about 50 seats out of usually clubs have
300 seats or something we do about 50
seats for a meet-and-greet and you pay a
little bit extra you get seated in the
front and then I meet people and shake
hands and take pictures after and all
that those are all selling out crazily
quickly so they sold out immediately I
asked the guys today to release ten more
so I'm not sure if they're still
available but you can check at Dave
Rubin dot-com slash events you can click
over there and see if there's any more
meet and greets available but will will
make it happen but you know here's what
we'll do
here's what this is gonna complicate
things for my guys a little bit but
anyone that donates if you donate 25
bucks or more a month during this live
stream will have your email address and
you we will email you if you want to
come to any of those shows and you can't
get tickets to the to the upgrade or you
don't even want you don't even have to
upgrade if you end up at the Irvine show
we'll gladly upgrade you to the
meet-and-greet I'll make sure it happens
we will do that so okay let's move on
thanks for the good fight Dave much
respect I appreciate it look at you nice
people being good on super chata and
every now and again I glance you know we
post the live stream this tells you a
little bit about the ecosystem of
YouTube but we we post the live stream
on YouTube and our glance before we get
on there about what's going on in the
comment section and I don't know what
you people are doing what do you people
do you're all fighting with each other
saying horrible things to each other
often the ones that amaze me the most
though I really mean this
and I just glanced for literally like
literally 30 seconds and it's like
there's all these people that seemingly
don't like me in this comment section
and I don't care if you don't like me I
actually don't but what I would say to
you is what are you doing with your life
get off this channel what are you doing
if you don't like me go find something
to do I mean there's plenty of other
things you could be doing right now you
could take a run you could play some
video games you can watch porn I mean
there's many other you can write I don't
know what do you do you could make
coffee
you could stare at a fish tank there's a
zillion things you could do better than
just endlessly sit there what are you
doing
tell me what you're doing if you're
watching this right now which I'm sure
you are what are you doing with your
life what can we do for you I would
recommend reading 12 rules for life by
Jordan Peterson that might help clean up
your own people okay oh by the way all
right so we should clarify something cuz
there seems to be a little confusion
here first off I thank you guys that are
all jumping in on super chat and I know
that's a cool way of getting your
heard and I'm reading them all right
here we're not censoring any of this
nonsense but the only way we're givin
away stuff again the shirts that are
right here which are in limited supply I
would love to get rid of them I need
some closet space you know my studio
this is my garage so I don't have a
garage anymore
we built a state-of-the-art studio here
and you know what I'll do will do I do
this for for patrons but I often do
videos where I just kind of wander
around and I show you the whole thing
and it's pretty awesome so if you
haven't seen what what sort of the
behind-the-scenes of this is is you guys
on patreon that and that the people that
have allowed us to fan fund you guys you
truly I mean it's not it's not a it's
not hyperbole or a sarcastic remark to
say that you made my dreams come true I
built I bought this house because you
guys I built this studio because you
guys we built the state of the art
studio when Tucker Carlson walked in
here a couple weeks ago he now think
about this girl's and is the number one
show on cable news I have no idea how
many millions of dollars a year he's
making but it's millions and millions of
dollars a year he walks into my garage
and he he literally I don't know if he's
gonna want me to quote him exactly but
it was something to be effective holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is your garage like he
was he was actually jealous of this cool
thing that we've been able to build here
and and my freedom and all that and
that's not a knock on Fox by him in any
way he loves what he's doing I was on
his show later that night and they treat
him great and he's you know he's become
a huge ally in this space of related to
free speech and the rest of it and he
gets the guy gets unending hate I mean
for the amount of hate that I get it's
like you attached Fox to your name and
now mainstream is just obsessed with you
because they just want the clicks that
and views that you're getting right and
that's why the more hate that I get the
more am I going I guess I am doing
something right because people say nice
things to me I'm like all right well I
guess I'm all right I'm doing what I
think is right but then all these people
that hate me I'm like boy you're really
spending a lot of time thinking about me
okay
but anyway because of fan funding we've
been able to do this but I don't have a
garage anymore so we don't have a lot of
storage space in a thousand if I can
move some of those boxes of mugs and
t-shirts that would actually be
wonderful shoutouts to Chris and
Christine are they a couple I do not
know we'll find out okay let's see gave
$50 on your site no place for us to
enter details on there right a heart on
my mug when you
sign it you glorious gay bastard love
you okay so if you gave money on the
site so we'll find out who that last
person was that gave 50 we then have
your email address and we will email you
with all of the information so fear not
will get you so I'm gonna sign the mug
for you right now I feel good about that
D right there that's a good D and you
want a heart on that thing you're gay
bastard all right no homo dude you got a
heart you got a heart too
all right there you go let's see okay
hey Dave are you gonna do anything on
comics gate and the blacklisting slash
daxing of people in the comics industry
so this thing keeps popping up I to be
totally honest with you my bandwidth try
to you know try to imagine what my
bandwidth is like at the moment to be
able to take in it like enough stories
that are related to all of the things
that are going out at this and try to do
all the things I'm trying to do every
now and again something that I know
should not get by me does get by me so I
know I need to pay more attention to
this and also like I come from the world
of comic books I love you know in our
green room here and I'll post some
videos of this also soon and I've done
it before for the behind-the-scenes
patreon thing that's what I was trying
to get to earlier I love comics I have
comics I have some of my old comic
collection posted in the green room
right over there so I know I need to
know more about this I know there's been
some like SJW madness related to comics
I know it's leaking into the video game
world and into everywhere oh I had a
question for you so this past weekend on
on Sunday I took a couple meetings in
the morning I try not to work on the
weekend but it never works I always end
up doing it but I had a couple hours in
the afternoon and it was pouring rain
here in LA and it never rains and I had
a couple hours in the afternoon to like
do nothing and I was actually like holy
[ __ ] I could actually do nothing right
now watch a couple episodes the Golden
Girls then I go into the green room here
so we one of the bedrooms in my house is
the green room and for those of you that
are on patreon you've seen we have a
great green room like it's totally
comfortable for all the guests we got an
espresso machine in there we got a fully
stocked fridge with whatever they want
in there we've got snacks in there I've
also got all my videogame systems in
there so I've got my old-school 8-bit
NES Nintendo
I got contra I got Super Mario I got the
original baseball I got bases loaded
I got what else I got I got I got pro
wrestling a lot of the classics I've got
a Sega Genesis in there with altered
beast and ghouls and ghosts and NBA live
and all that stuff I've got a
PlayStation 4 the calamari already got
me I've got a Nintendo switch that a fan
got me and I think that's it on the
video game department anyway so I was
like I'm gonna play some video games so
first I played my brother-in-law you
know first I played my nephew in NBA 2k
19 and I was thinking you know maybe one
of the rewards for people that are high
tier donors maybe I would start giving
out my my handle on PlayStation 4 and
every now and again I'd play people in
NBA Live or NBA 2k whatever it is or in
some other co-op games I really I like
co-op games where we're working together
I don't need to fight you and blow your
brains out and spit your guts all over
the place or punch a hooker if we can
work together to fix the world that
that's more of my thing
so if you can think of a good so my
question is this so first off my my that
that patron works my nephew my 9 year
old nefra first up he kicked my ass in
NBA 2k was pathetic
it was he use the Warriors now of course
you're using the Warriors you got
Thompson you got you got you got curry
ok I get it you know you got Jesus
Christ oh my god Durant you know they're
they're unstoppable basically I was
using the 91 Trail Blazers which is
probably my it's my second favorite
basketball team of all time except for
the 95 Rockets and he just mopped me I
like to be beaten by 30 points by a
nine-year-old he's pathetic
then I played my brother-in-law he
crushed me he although he was the 93
Bulls which you know you're using Jordan
in his prime and then and then I was
like alright I'm gonna play by myself
like what can I play and everything I
don't want to run all over the place and
have to spend all this mental energy on
a world that I don't live in I spend a
lot of mental energy on this world here
that I seem to be living in so I
couldn't I ended up playing pacman I
literally ended up playing pacman on
PlayStation 4 because I couldn't find
something sort of mindless and simple so
if you've got a simple mindless game
that would be great I also like but I
like just bullet hell shooters so if
you've got a couple good sides play an R
type and resogun and a couple of others
I don't really have time for any of this
frankly but if you've got some
good ideas let me know alright guys here
we go
my team wants me to do a little reset
here I'm giving shoutouts for anyone
that donates at all if you donate five
bucks in a bub it doesn't matter
I'm giving live shoutouts Dave Rubin
comm / donate if you donate $25 or above
monthly you're gonna get a limited
edition Reuben reports select member
shirt that will never be printed again I
think we've about a hundred of them left
probably less than that maybe about 80
of them left and you'd be cleaning our
closet space for me which would really
be great because I don't have a garage
anymore so we don't have a lot of room
run out here that would be great we'll
give you a t-shirt and for 50 bucks a
month or more you're gonna get the
t-shirt and you're gonna get a mug and
I'm gonna sign it for you and we're
gonna send it out to you this week so do
let me know what's going on over there
Canada loves you Dave thank you I love
Canada I get a ton of email from Canada
I did about 10 Canadian stops with JP in
Canada and I think a Canada there's an
interesting resurgence of Liberty in
Canada which is really interesting me
actually we're gonna have libertarian
Prime Minister candidate prime
ministerial candidate Maxine Bernier is
gonna be on the show we were gonna do it
via Skype but I just got an email this
morning he's coming here coming directly
to the studio Maxine Bernier will be
here within the next week or so so we'll
do that one you know what let's jump
over to the to the computer monitor as
it were I'm gonna hit refresh
let sit please tell me that you people
have canceled this thing you're killing
me you're killing me stop giving me
money here all right we drop 14 people
we're down to 17 hundred and fifty-seven
people still around $10,000 I don't know
what I can do what are you doing cancel
this stop please people you don't have
to donate it anymore even on my website
if you don't want but but please let's
end this thing why are we giving these
people money all right let's see okay
shout out to James thank you very much
I'm a college student who goes to a
campus that is extremely liberal and I'm
somewhat of a libertarian any advice for
me not to get killed but still the free
speech well that's the state of affairs
if you believe in liberty and freedom
and you don't want to bother anybody and
you don't want to take their [ __ ] but
you don't want them to take your [ __ ]
you know you might be getting killed
my advice would be this which is this is
the exact same advice that I give every
college kid when I go to every college
speaking gig that I do which is be brave
now that's it
you must be brave now you will not get
out of college really really hear this I
think this is the most true thing that I
can possibly say if you're in college
right now and you're afraid to say what
you think do you think that it magically
is gonna get better if you think things
are screwed up and maybe the generation
before you is the one that screwed them
up do you think that it will magically
get better by your silence do you think
that the people who are loud right now
will eventually give you an inch because
of your acquiescence no they will keep
taking and taking and taking and that's
why what happened to me with this
patreon thing was all right we could let
them they booted some people and we we
maybe drop the ball on some or ignored
some or that person was shady or I
didn't want to make that one the exact
example of why I would stand up and and
defend the line but then the line moves
the line moves and if you're afraid to
say what you think now you're 18 you're
19 years old and if you think that it
will magically get better it will not it
will get worse we live in the most
privileged in the best sense of it we're
pretty if you live in the United States
you are privileged you are the freest
person in the freest society that there
possibly is it doesn't mean you have
everything it doesn't mean you came from
everything it doesn't mean you'll attain
everything but you live in a place that
will give you the opportunity to do all
of the things that you want in your life
but it's on you to do them it's on you
to do them so if you're 18 or 19 years
old and you're in college right now and
you're afraid to say what you think if
you don't do it now it'll never get
easier do you think when you get out of
college in 3 years and now you got a
rent you got to pay rent right well
you're gonna suddenly be like I'm gonna
tell the world what I think and then
three years later you're married and you
got a mortgage I'm gonna tell the world
what I think you got car payments a dog
now you got kids it's three months later
now or three years later now you got all
sorts of other payments school payments
and ba ba ba I'm building for I'm gonna
tell the world I think you won't you
won't it's on you now there's no better
moment than right this moment to start
saying what you think and part of the
reason
this SJW lunacy is is spreading is
because they're loud and they call
everyone racist so they've silenced good
people there is I assure you guys look
I'm doing the best I can I'm just doing
what I think is right I say that all the
time I am just one person and guess what
I'm still here and Douglas Murray
Douglas Murray who I think is one of the
greatest modern thinkers that we have
who I've had in the studio if you
haven't seen our interviews watch it
and Douglas Maher he talks about
extremely controversial talk topics he
talks about radical Islam he talks about
immigration a whole bunch of things and
he's gay and conservative in in the UK I
asked him well what makes you so brave
why are you willing to talk about these
things what you meaning you is this
person in front of me why are you
willing to talk about these things and
he said and in a wonderful British
accent that I can't quite do but he said
you know Dave when you get in the pool
you might find out that the water is not
that cold I wish I could have done that
with a little more of a cockney Downton
Abbey accent but the point is that if
you guys jump in you might find out that
all the things that you fear are not as
terrible the monster isn't as terrible
and I'm says I'm not saying the monster
doesn't exist because it does exist but
we got to start fighting back together
and if you think at 18 if you stop if
you're thinking about these things now
you know what let's try it this way
imagine if my advice was you know what
suck it up suck it up get out of college
does that seem like the right advice I
don't think so we'll see let's see
always enjoy your perspective on what's
going on in this crazy world come to
Oklahoma City we're figuring out the
stand-up tour so hang tight on Oklahoma
City looking forward to seeing you in
San Jose next week and thanks for the
meet-and-greet comps I guess I gave you
meet and greet comps my pleasure you
said before that you're a Sinatra fan
what's your favorite song or album by
Frank I love the question I love not
getting always political questions if
you guys want to ask me anything else
that's not political that would be great
too oh quick shout outs to Mary - Kelly
- Phillip thank you guys Dave Rubin comm
/ donate let me give you a shirt and a
mug people I'm moving product and we're
officially deleting patreon will delete
and look like it's gonna be about an
hour we're gonna delete this thing
unless I just magically do it out of
nowhere I could just get sick of this
and just
I'm hungry and I got to go but we are
deleting patreon live I love the fact
that like there are these like Silicon
Valley like people watching like oh my
god is he gonna do it when's he gonna do
it what does this mean it's like it's so
boring the groupthink thing it's just so
boring
my favorite Sinatra song by far by far
my way by far every word of that song is
something that I try to live up to it's
just I'm not I'm not gonna sing it for
you right now but open up another
YouTube tab and listen to my way and
that is that is how I try to live my
life I don't always succeed at it but
it's just great listen to the line about
regrets regrets I've had a few I mean
just just listen it's just it's just
perfection but you know believe it or
not I actually think pound for pound if
I could only listen to Frank Sinatra or
Dean Martin if I had to choose between
one of the two I might go Dean Martin I
really really love Dean Martin
especially when when David's cooking
Italian I could listen to D Martin all
the time d Martin's a little lighter
there's like a little more play and be
more and then there is in Sinatra and I
really do love that oh okay sorry Mary
Kelly and Philip I didn't I didn't
realize you guys were mugs sorry I'm
gonna sign your mugs what I do at the
pen all right here we go Mary you're
getting a mug by the way guys do not
I've been warned about this if you put
this mug with the signature in the in
the dishwasher it will rub off so either
hand wash it or I was told if you bake
them but I don't want to be held legally
responsible finis if you bake the mug
that somehow the ink like gets into the
mug and you'll be okay so that is Mary
that is Kelly and Philip and you guys
are all getting t-shirts as well thank
you guys all right there we go
all right you know what I said I said
504 shot we'll do 200 for a shot on on
super jet go for it
shoutout to you evolve thank you very
much let's see um
to do to do if he ever gets out of the
embassy Giuliana sighs would be a great
guest yeah I'd be happy to talk to him I
wonder if we could do that via Skype
he's done a couple interviews
think I would obviously be more than
happy to do that hey Dave I'm doing $50
a month have you had a chance to look at
Christina Bichons work she's a professor
at Oxford and wrote a book about
political civility I'd the name actually
does not ring a bell I will tell you
this I went to well person up guys can
we add her name to the list be shy on bi
Jo Ann I went to Oxford twice in the
last year I spoke at Oxford Union which
the videos on YouTube on their YouTube
channel it was one of the greatest
honors that I've welcomed it might be
the greatest professional honor that
I've had it was just an incredible place
to be I mean if you go to Oxford if you
haven't been there it looks like it's
right out of Harry Potter it's it's just
incredible and they you know they have
these small schools everywhere and
there's such a respect for learning and
knowledge and the libraries are
incredible and there's just young people
everywhere who are interested in
knowledge it's it's actually amazing I
had a what I think was one of my best
public talks it was extremely intimate
and and really lovely I got asked some
really challenging questions at the end
some really interesting stuff and it was
it was a pleasure to do that and then I
went back again with Jordan a couple
months ago and it's just a great place
and and I'll you know I've mentioned
this before but going around the world
you know in the last couple months I was
in I was in Norway I'll just mention the
countries not all the cities but I was
in Ireland I was in Norway I was in
Sweden I was in Denmark I was in did I
say Ireland already I was in the UK
obviously we're in the States we were in
Canada we're gonna be doing in France
and Germany and we're trying to get to
the Middle East and a whole bunch of
other places in the next couple of
months but seeing that these ideas
permeate around the world and the people
I mean try to think how cool it is that
somebody right now there's somebody in
Brazil watching this thinking a similar
thought as someone in Iceland who's
thinking of some similar thought is
someone is in Jordan as someone in
Russia I mean that that's actually
incredible and that's a really beautiful
thing and that's why the internet has to
be protected and that's why we have to
protect free thought and it's why we
have to protect our ability to
communicate each other with each other
so let's keep doing that Kyle you're
getting a mug all right let's go
keep fighting the good fight Dave all
right that's the plan that is the plan
Kyle you are getting a mug thank you
very much
all right quick reset since we're about
an hour in or you know let's go to the
let's go to the computer over here we
are not on the computer now please tell
me that we lost at least a hundred
people I don't know what to do here to
get rid of you people
17:57 we are down to 1756 that's right
people in the twenty minutes since I did
that we lost one person and I thank you
whoever that is you know what I want to
send that person um I will send that
person a mug if we can find out who that
person is I want to send them a mug and
a t-shirt if you just cancel it on
patreon thank you I don't know what I
can do for you guys so I have to send
you guys money maybe I should start a
Kickstarter to raise money to give money
to you people to cancel the patreon
thing lordy Lordy a mug for Carrie
you're getting a mug sister thank you
for support it's much appreciated
all right people I'm ready to do another
shot of patron I don't know what's
happened here let's let's make it happen
200 on super chat or or you know what a
hundred monthly on Dave Rubin dot-com /
donate we'll make it happen I don't know
I'm just having fun here like let's just
keep rolling you're a legend Dave keep
up the good work can't wait to see you
in Australia I really can't wait to go
to Australia I get a ton of email from
Australia Australia I think is our
fourth most listened-to country usually
it's the United States Canada UK and
then and then I think Australia in
Germany or sometimes Australia and
Sweden flip on that on the next most
foul no Sweden's a particularly
interesting case cuz there's only about
ten people that live there and I think I
think I met everybody at the two shows
with Jordan the second show that I did
with Jordan in Stockholm which was an
amazing theatre and they were two of my
favorite shows I really loved all the
Nordic countries actually but the day
before we did the second show with
Jordan the Swedish foreign minister
whose name is escaping me at the moment
might be Kirsten something Kristen
Kristen something she said that she
wishes that Jordan Peterson would crawl
back under the rock he came from of the
Foreign Minister of a western country
was upset that a clinical psychologist
who talks about free
and personal responsibility and the
rights of the individual and and
defending the the values of Western
society she wants him to crawl back
under the rock that he's came from I
mean that's how stupid everything is
gotten though I do have to thank her
because I got a lot of good laughs at
her expense
super chat thank you for doing what you
do Dave you got it
hey I signed up for 50 hours a month I
was wondering what your favorite car was
man these Tesla's right now have you
guys been in these Tesla's they are on
freakin unbelievable like driving a
Tesla and then drive in any other car
the newest anything and you will be like
wow what a jump in technology I mean
they are smooth and clean there's no
buttons it's all on that huge screen
there they're self-driving you know the
Model X has the the DeLorean style wings
they're just absolutely like sick and
cool there's a ton of them here in LA
and on top of the fact they're fully
electric obviously and everything else
and a lot musk shot one into space just
because he could I mean that that's
something the Minister of Foreign
Affairs in Sweden is margot wallström
that's right margot wallström she is not
Kirsten anything I made that up
let's see when you interview Maxine
Bernier ask him about the dairy industry
he says he wants to follow in
Australia's path however Australian
farmers killed themselves and shop in
shocking numbers when they eliminated
quotas
I will be totally honest with you I
don't know anything about that let me do
a little research I'll try to make it
happen okay um non-political question
ginger or Mary Ann oh sorry I forgot
Julie
Gilligan or skipper what's wrong with
you people you know like really you what
kind of question is that
skipper obviously but what's wrong with
you you know it's just an odd question
why are you asking that shot mug for
Christian all right here you go
Christian thank you guys you know one of
the things that you're also doing in the
meantime so we are building out this
platform as I said we're trying to
figure out ways to secure the
monetization we're trying to figure out
ways to secure the video hosting to
secure not only that but the web hosting
there's ways to diiie central
is that even we're trying to figure out
all of the pressure points and how do we
deal with them systematically and make
sure that we're taking a care of on all
fronts we're trying to figure out what
it what is the terms of service in 2019
what does a true Terms of Service look
like should it be as simple as it's just
you have to follow the laws of the
United States where we have no hate
speech laws but you can't you know make
a terrorist threat or yell fire in a
crowded theater or a criminal threat or
direct violence things like that could
it be that well there's an argument that
that could be it I think that's a legit
argument but then what happens the day
we open this platform all of the the
racists and the white supremacists and
all these awful people let's say they
get on on the site now I'm not against
them expressing their free speech I
think you guys obviously know that even
if I find their ideas and whorin the
problem is that imagine now we start
this site and out of the first two
thousand accounts 1500 of them are these
people because they've been banned off
the other site well now what is the
entire media and we know the media is
just mostly a bunch of nonsense anyway
the entire media now jumps on board and
is oh you see Rubin and Peterson are
running the alt-right racist website and
then you know we will hopefully have
investors and board members and all that
and then all the pressure is applied on
them so we have to lift a calculatingly
and clearly think about what is the
Terms of Service look like how do you
launch a launch a new platform does a
platform have to be launched then on day
one everyone's on it or should it be I'm
coming around to this idea that it would
be a tiered invitation system so let's
say we launch with say 50 people right
so let's say it's like sort of IDW
people and adjacent people and then
that's sort of the beta test version of
it right as the creator but anyone can
sign on to follow a creator but that's
the creator tier and then maybe over
three months as we're testing all things
out each creator gets five invites to
five other creators and then you
exponentially grow from there I think
something like that could be interesting
I also think people are sick of the fact
that anyone can get on anything and do
whatever they want and the whole things
are free for all I think actually people
do like some rules but they like them to
be actually enforced consistently not in
this crazy way that they're enforced
right now shout out to Kody
thank you very much Cody if I remember
your if I remember correctly you were
ablaze
fan I think the Blazers get rid of
either Lillard or McCullen if they don't
make a deep playoff push so I'm an early
90s Blazers fan because Clyde Drexler
was my favorite hero if you weren't an
NBA fan in the early 90s Clyde the glide
was basically the number to shooting
guard to Jordan for all of those years
and I just like the guy he was smooth he
didn't make a big stink about everything
he was in a showboater he got his team's
to the NBA Finals twice in 90 against
the Pistons in 92 against the Bulls and
then in 91 they made it to the Western
Conference Finals against the Lakers he
lost a couple championships and by the
time he was he was really an old guy 32
years old in 95 he was traded to the
Houston Rockets where he had played for
the Houston Cougars phi slamma jamma
with the chemo elijah juan he was traded
to houston and he won a championship
that's my favorite team of all time so I
don't know exactly how much is going on
with the Blazers right now I don't want
Lillard to overtake Clyde though in all
time Blazers are scoring so I'm hoping
that's not gonna happen
okay there we go I'm dying to take you
and Jordan out for a beer let me know
when you're gonna be in Vegas I do a
show on the strip I'd love to drink my
crown Royale from your autograph mug the
autographed mug does go well with crown
Royale I didn't make it to Vegas I don't
know you know there's a couple cities
that people have asked about that I'm
not totally sure why this or that didn't
happen you know there's all sorts of
considerations on a tour that they try
to figure out and I don't know exactly
what the answer to that was alright here
we go I'm going to jump back to the to
the computer screen there we're trying
to get you people off patreon so I'm
gonna hit refresh come on people tell me
you dropped on patreon and I don't want
money on patreon 17:56
and 17:55 this is going to be the
longest this is gonna be the livestream
from hell people trying to get you
people to cancel I don't know what I can
do I'm deleting it either way so no
matter what happens at 7 o'clock tonight
a couple minutes before 7:00 I'll do it
you know look I can leave this thing up
and just cash in on that and I could
probably cash in on it for a long time
because people sign up for things and
forget I'm obviously not gonna do that
but I would love to see more people
cancel this thing at least but in the
meantime as we roll
a whole bunch of this stuff we are
moving people over to my website so if
you donate five bucks or more I'm giving
you a shout out right now it's Dave
Rubin comm session donate twenty five
bucks or more a month you're getting a
t-shirt fifty bucks or more a month
you're getting a signed autographed mug
and and yeah let's do another shot of
patronum I'm feeling it at this point
let's make it happen let's see I just
got here are you aware of youtuber laws
FTC complaint he's working against
patreon and PayPal would you have him on
your channel so I know of this video and
I've heard about this guy I actually
haven't watched it yet but it sounds
like there might be some legal issue
related to collusion or something like
that I need to know a little bit more
about it before I specifically comment
on anything
look my preference on all of these
things would not go be going through
legal routes although sometimes there's
a need to do it and and going through
governmental force although I guess
sometimes perhaps there's a need to do
it I know that sets bells off with the
libertarian set my preference would be
that human ingenuity and and creativity
and the human mind will resolve problems
I think that's the way it's always been
done in the best ways in human history
and I think that's what can be done here
mug time Jim you're getting a mug there
you go Jim thank you very much welcome
to the team and a shout out to Nicole
thank you very much let's see super chat
I got called a white supremacist alt
writer today for retweeting Dave's tweet
about Family Guy self censoring gay
jokes due to sjw pressure the world is
upside-down so if you haven't seen this
I tweeted this yesterday there was an
article in Entertainment Tonight or one
of these type of sites that the
producers of Family Guy have decided
that they're gonna phase out gay jokes
now I tweeted about this because I want
you to really think about how bananas is
and when people say oh this sjw stuff
doesn't matter and this free speech
stuff doesn't matter it's just happening
on college campuses and it's just a
bunch of kids and all of that it this is
why it is utter and complete nonsense
we need humor to laugh at things we need
the ability to release some
sometimes we need to be able to make fun
of people and sometimes groups and all
these things so to show that we're all
equal watch and watch Don Rickles do in
comedy go on YouTube later and watch Don
Rickles do comedy and he made fun of
everybody he made fun of Jews and gays
and Christians and white trash and
Asians and everybody and it made
everyone in the audience realize well
we're all part of the American
experiment but what the left is doing by
judging us so intensely on our immutable
characteristics is these are the people
who are obsessed with our differences
and they want us to be exactly the same
at the same time because their their
ideology has no logic and that's why
they're so angry all the time and that's
why they're so bitter and resentful and
that's why they're they're always trying
to deep LAT form people because they
don't want to debate ideas so the
problem with this family guy thing is
that first off let's just put aside
whether family guys funny or any anymore
it had a couple good years for sure
I really respect Seth MacFarlane
basically I like the guy I think he's
probably a decent guy he has made
millions and millions maybe hundreds of
millions of dollars I have no idea on
being politically incorrect think about
the characters the old gay child
molester that always wants to molest
Chris Mort Mort Goldman is the worst
Jewish stereotype you can possibly
imagine the other two gay guys in the
show the episode where Peter becomes gay
everything in everything in the show is
a is an awful stereotype but it's it's
either funny or it's not funny but you
that's up for you to decide for them to
say ah we've no and I'm not saying Seth
made this decision specifically and by
the way I've been fighting them on the
show many times I would love to sit him
down
sit down with him and I'm not judging
him specifically for this but then the
Machine of Family Guy made a ton of
money being offensive to all sorts of
people and now you know we're in our
twilight nobody really cares about us
anymore now we're going to turn against
what we've done this is like when you
see Sarah Silverman
now chide comedians for being
politically incorrect or I remember when
my Lowe's book was coming out she was
tweeting about that Simon & Schuster
should drop the book so now we have
comedians for getting rid of books
that's pretty close to book burning
that's the modern sense of book burning
that has nothing to do with anyone's
feelings about Milo
these people have become
darica land the hectoring things that
they should be making fun of if George
Carlin was alive today what do you think
George Carlin would be doing about bad
ideas he'd be mocking them not demanding
that we don't tell jokes about certain
things we don't let certain people
publish books now that's the whole
reason I got back into stand-up even
though it was like the last thing that I
wanted to do I want people to see that
you can laugh about these things and
guess what I go up there and I look
around the crowd and I make fun of
everybody and then that includes myself
so I think we can fix this stuff but I
think we can fix it through through
comedy mostly so come out to one of my
stand-up shows January 30th I'll be at
the Irvine improv Dave Rubicon slash
events shout out to Jason thank you very
much on super chat your biggest issue
will be that PayPal Visa and MasterCard
but I want to read this correctly your
biggest issue will be PayPal Visa and
MasterCard that forced you to shut down
not the backlash if you go a hundred
percent free speech no one can pay you
then and that's how you shut you down so
I may have missed a word in there okay
so this is an issue right so if right
now at dave rubin calm slash donate if
you use your credit card you can donate
through stripe which you which is PayPal
you know it's credit cards so you can
donate to any credit card it's a payment
processor I have no reason to think that
stripe is going to get rid of me
although they have gotten rid of some
other people but I have no reason to
think that's gonna happen to me but this
isn't just about me obviously I have no
reason to think that PayPal is gonna get
rid of me and again if just think about
this for a second let's pretend you're
right and you might be right if we're
really worried that that someone like me
let's say could actually potentially be
stopped from making financial
transactions in the United States then
then think about the level of tyranny
we're really talking about it if you're
saying that's here now well then again
we better start talking about this [ __ ]
and fast so I do think the answer is
partly lies within crypto we are now
taking Bitcoin on right there below
PayPal and the credit card thing you can
see our Bitcoin wallet it's on there and
as I said we're I'm also talking to a
whole bunch of other payment processors
there's ways there's creative ways
people that figured out to do all sorts
of commerce online and we're exploring
all of those options so hang tight but
if you are right and if you're watching
this and you think that that guy's
comment might be right then man we
better fix this quick
otherwise we're really were far more
screwed than you might think okay um
I donated five dollars a month and I
didn't get a shout out I'm sad now
anyway best shooter ever is radiant
Silvergun it was a Saturn game I missed
the sega saturn we were doing shout outs
if you do it on dave rubin comm sesh
donate so you might have done it on
super chat cuz that's where I just saw
that so I don't for say I don't know
your name you didn't say it there okay
let's see let's see any news on the
patreon replacement my whole platoon at
Fort Bliss Texas is wondering when you
will be in Texas next well first off
thank you guys for your service most
importantly did a whole bunch of shows
with Jordan in Texas we did Dallas we
did San Antonio which I loved I had
never been there before I've been to
Dallas a bunch of times we did Houston
which was really cool to be and it was
humid as [ __ ]
there it is hot in the summer in Houston
I will definitely be back there I think
I'm gonna do a public event with with
Glenn Beck at some point probably in the
Dallas area and I should look into doing
some stand-up in in Texas so hang tight
on that okay let's see where are we at
please tell me we dropped at least two
people you're killing me here people
what do we got on patreon right now
we're at 1 7 1 1755 I'm clicking refresh
all right that's what I'm talking about
dropped six people but our money went up
our money went up am I correct I am
correct what was our money at before we
just went up like a thousand bucks on
patreon what this is the Internet this
is as Internet II as it gets this is
this is the Internet I am trying to lose
money on patreon and our money on
patreon is going up you're funny
whoever you did whoever you are and I'm
assuming it's one person points for you
you know what you know what this is
messed up I don't want to do this but
just because the persons are hot that's
a high level troll who puts their money
where their mouth is we know who it is
we'll figure it out because you donate
it on patreon so we get an email I'm
giving you a mug even though that's
really messed up you're getting a mug
your [ __ ] all right there you go
you're getting a mug the money's going
up ridiculous all right guys we got
about 40 minutes left I a little bit
before 7:00 I will delete patreon no
matter I could be a twenty five thousand
dollars a month we're gonna delete this
thing I do not know what to say to
people like you let's see the book the
coddling of the American mind is an
amazing book it's a must read during
these times well I've had oh that's
Jonathan hate who I've had on the show
years ago we almost had him back on two
weeks ago he was in LA but it we
couldn't quite work it out I will
definitely get him back on hang on that
Marcin
thank you is that my old friend marching
from from New York could that be could
that be him I used to have an old buddy
marchin ma our CIN in New York is that
him could that be you you got a sign
mugged my friend oh I think you just did
a shout-out but you know what you're
probably getting the mug because I read
that off the wrong thing okay let's see
uh $99.99 take a shot love you Dave mad
respect you know what for doing 99.99 a
shot of patron for you there you go we
don't mess around here this is this is a
pretty big shot glass - all right we're
gonna get a little salt here we go all
right little salt no patron
I like tequila I do like tequila I'm a
red wine drinker as most of you guys
really know I like Napa Reds mostly or
northern calorie Reds I really like
Italian Reds lately so I really only
drink wine but I do like tequila when it
when it comes around um I think it's a
different Martin he was known as Martin
even though his Marsan or Marcin but I
believe it's a different marching but
hello Marcin how are you okay
bad boys Pistons versus up-and-coming
Bulls was my favorite NBA time made you
laugh with the ginger Mary question that
was the point all right there you go
yeah you know I hated those Pistons the
bad boys Pistons to me that wasn't
basketball I hated Bill Laimbeer they
also beat my Blazers in 1990 which was a
very underrated series all the games
were within two or three points and one
of the games I think it was Game three
what's the game three it was game mode I
think was game four or five Danny young
who was a scrub backup on the Blazers he
hit a shot at half-court that would have
got the game into overtime that they
waved off at the buzzer but it was it
was a great series shout out to Ricardo
welcome on board Ricardo let's see
is Ian McGilchrist on your radar yet his
book is enlightening and the way it
explores how our divided brain alters
behavior culture and society given the
name sounds vaguely familiar but I can't
say he fully is guys can we put Ian
McGilchrist on the list 100 bucks this
is the weirdest pledge drive I've ever
seen lol this is I'm trying to lose
money in effect at some level I suppose
and we're gaining if I press this right
now and there's more money in there I'm
actually gonna punch the camera here we
go
we have 1749 patrons ten thousand six
hundred twenty dollars all right let's
see it drop let's see it drop wait a
minute what happened there we lost five
we lost five dollars people that's what
I'm talking about lost five dollars how
many people did we lose there a couple
people we lost five dollars whatever
you do please people I implore you for
the sake of free speech in America for
the future of the First Amendment do not
donate at patreon.com slash Rubin Report
I'm deleting it don't go there I mean go
there to delete but don't go there for
anything else we got to end this thing
it's a nightmare
shout out to Kim thank you very much Kim
I'm starting to wish you chose January
for your annual social media blackout
that's funny that's funny I do August
off the grid you know I'm gonna really
push I think this year as many people as
possible to join me on this thing I do a
30-day cleanse I mean that's the only
way I can describe it completely off the
grid no phone I locked my phone in a
safe which I don't know the code to no
television which it's almost impossible
to avoid television it's really a part
to avoid news because hey you got to
tell everybody that you're not listening
to the news cuz I try not to get
anything in my brain during that you
know I'm doing other things but I try
not to get the day-to-day news in my
brain because it's just we're just
endlessly hit with information I don't
think this is the way we were always
wired to be maybe it's the future it's
the next evolution of being a human but
I don't think it's supposed to be like
this all the time but I realized the
hardest part of being off the grid is
that everywhere that there is a muted
television there is CNN every airport
muted television CNN every burger joint
muted television CNN you go to the gym
you did television CNN if it what I
don't know that anyone's listening to
set to CNN with the words which would be
[ __ ] it's hilarious if you do but uh
yeah yeah I highly recommend doing a
little off the great thing I try to do
it on the weekends too to the best
degree that I can not as not as strictly
as I did in August but this this August
I think I'm gonna try to get as many
people as possible to do it a shout-out
to Keith what are we doing here guys
quick reset we're moving to everybody
off patreon and we're trying to get
people in Dave Rubin comm slash donate
it is the first of about five steps over
the next couple months that I'm doing
too just to get true independents to
have true sort of ownership over our
content and audience and the rest of it
we're gonna remain fully funded by you
guys which is fantastic I have no boss
no one has ever told me anything to do
or say on this show we do what we want I
do what I think is right for what for
all the the positives and negatives of
all of that so we are doing a little
fundraising here today
and then deleting patreon 25 bucks
you're getting the last remaining Rubin
report patreon select t-shirts and I'm
gonna sign a mug for ya for $50 or more
a month
shout out to Raymon thank you very much
ha hey Dave is Gillette the best a man
can get
I mean Gillette's like I've just had it
with you people you know anyway and it's
like you don't have to turn on half the
people to bow to the social justice God
you don't have to make men look toxic
and and it's just ridiculous pandering
idiocy and you know it's interesting
there's this meme of go get won't go
broke implying that the companies are
gonna fail because of this I don't know
that that's actually true maybe they are
making more money because of this but
it's not good and it's not right and
guess what I don't give a [ __ ] about the
politics of the company I get my razors
from although I can tell you that going
forward I would go out of my way not to
buy a Gillette product for sure it's
like Ben & Jerry's did that resist ice
cream I don't even think Ben & Jerry's
is that good anymore I really like
McConnell's ice cream which is a
Creamery in Santa Barbara up here I
don't know that they're all over that
they're nationwide but if you live in
the California area and probably west
coast mcconnell's ice cream is awesome
they got a they got a cookies and cream
that is fantastic in a sea salt
something or other that is amazing but
anyway it's like alright if you guys are
putting all in that we're going in
hashtag resists like I just don't want
to give you my money and then people
will say well Dave you're a hypocrite
because you still eat a chick-fil-a
there's like chick-fil-a
isn't putting were for we're against gay
marriage on their chicken sandwiches the
owner once gave a couple hundred bucks
to some anti-gay marriage thing or
something to that effect it's like who
cares people are allowed to do private
things in their private lives and it's
like you guys think that if you could
only control the way everybody thinks
and the way everyone behaves that the
world would be better and I think the
world would actually be much worse I
don't care what anyone does or thinks as
long as they don't do it to me or on my
property just don't touch me that's
really all I ask
let's go to patreon and watch this thing
dump out because I know you people are
canceling for me so right now we're at
1747 patrons we're at ten thousand six
hundred fifteen dollars please have
dropped we're up fifty two dollars
look I get what the Internet is you know
I get it you're funny you're funny
people having a good time you know
watching the livestream you know
watching the YouTube or do YouTube
you're killing me I have to leave this
thing I have to go please stop putting
money there you think this is funny
this isn't funny this is my life 50
bucks on super chat signed the mug to my
wife just fee Effie so you in Orlando
and loved it and don't be a wuss slam
that tequilla like we do in Texas
alright fee you're getting a mug he's
getting a mug he is a great lady fee
Effie and I'm putting an exclamation
point for her because I feel good about
fee and I'm signing the mug that Orlando
show was one of my favorite shows I say
it all about a lot of the shows and I do
mean it when I say it that Orlando show
is fantastic that theater was gorgeous I
think those Disney it was like the
Disney something theater I think the
Disney people are gonna be okay
financially by the way that was a great
great great great show we did four shows
in four nights in Florida and that that
Orlando one has stuck at the ones that
really stuck out with me the Atlanta one
because it was Jordan's birthday Orlando
was amazing Grand Rapids Michigan I
think might have been the best show we
did and and the first time we were in
Calgary we blew the roof off the place
it was it was actually legitimately
crazy it was it was bananas bonkers
shout out to Raymon thank you very much
okay thanks for standing on principle
Dave yeah my pleasure
do you think there is hope to end this
far left path that we're on first up I
got to take some water I'm choking so I
cannot believe people are still donating
to patreon this is like I feel like I'm
in dream I mean actually an episode of
black mirror this is black mirror this
is it we're in Bandersnatch right now
you guys are picking my future you know
anyway like bananas
the question was what the hell was the
question oh there was a question there
what what it's there [ __ ] do you think
there's there's an end to the far-left
pathway look this thing has to implode
one way or another the question is how
bad will it get before it implodes and
how much power it will attain before it
implodes that is that that is the true
question here when when Cortes or some
of these people talk about seventy
percent marginal tax rate and then
people scream well bit they should have
it and and you know they know they're
not gonna take 70% of your money they
mean above ten million dollars now let's
pretend now I don't make time anything
dollars I don't make a million dollars a
year let's pretend for a second that
that you made ten million dollars a year
let's pretend you made twenty million
dollars person watching this right now
you figured out how to do something you
created something of value something you
made a product you made a candy bar you
made a video game you sold a wine you
are an incredibly successful locksmith
whatever the hell you are you're now
making fifteen million dollars a year
now basically the federal government
when you're making that much money
you're in the top 1% let's say I'm just
doing rough numbers here the government
is gonna tax you at basically 37% right
now at that point now if you own your
own business you can write off some
stuff and let's say you can get that
down to about 30% what she is proposing
is that over 10 million dollars that you
take in the government should take 70%
of that now for young people and the
socialist crew of America that all
sounds good you don't need that money
you don't deserve that money you didn't
build that all of those things and it
just sounds right it sounds right like
you should give back more why do you
need that much money
except that has nothing to do with truth
or what's right what right does someone
have because they feel because some
government bureaucrat feels that they
should take from you who created to give
to someone who did not create even if
their intentions are good what gives
them the right to do it I would say they
have no right to do it but this is the
new left and and some would argue this
is the old left like some old school
guys I think if Prager was sitting here
or Shapiro they say this is what it all
was I don't know that it always was this
way because I think there used to be a
decent left and I think it's important
that we have a decent left once again
this is a horrible set of ideas and
that's not just the only part of this
that's a horrible set of ideas the fact
that Tameka Lao Mallory who was one of
the leaders of the women's March was on
the view yesterday the day before and
couldn't condemn outright Louis
Farrakhan who calls Jews cockroaches and
a zillion other things and he's also met
with what's-her-name up in California
the other congresswoman I'm blanking on
her name for a second and all of all of
these people they're in bed with a lot
of bad people and and you can see this
thing coming and it judges us all in our
worst ways and it and it believes it
believes that the state is the ultimate
power and think of the irony of this
Trump is in charge these are the paint
the same people who think that Trump is
a Russian asset and that and if you
agree that Trump is a Russian asset and
I say this as someone that did not even
vote for Trump but if you believe that
Trump is a Russian asset you actually
think we're at World War 3 right now
what could be a higher declaration of
war than having the having installed the
President of the United States so if you
think it's a good idea that we should
impeach the president or something to
that effect or if you think really that
Russia installed the president United
States then understand what the pet that
what you believe is the path to World
War 3 now if the if they did install the
president then all right I guess we're
on path to World War 3 or could this
just be a bunch of paranoid lunacy for a
bunch of people who were in power and
lost power and that's why I would say
that the best answer to any of this is
limit power limit power and that what
that means is that when your guys in
power not that much will change but
guess what it's pretty damn good in
America yeah it is and then what that
also means is when the guy that you
don't like is in power not that much bad
can change and guess what it's pretty
good in America so that's the
negotiation to live in a free stable
Western society it can move on the
margins but when when Cortes gets out
there and says I'm gonna tax these
people at 70 percent and says to Joe
Lieberman who dis you're the future
you're the past it's like you think that
are basically a part
tender thinks that she knows how to run
the world and by the way if you think
that she's the one really tweeting all
of this stuff or that there isn't a
whole congregation of people that decide
what she can tweet I think you're sorely
mistaken but again I will 100% be glad
to interview her and treat her with the
exact same respect I would treat any
other guest we will air it live I won't
even do use questions I will sit here
with nothing and other than myself and
talk to her I would be happy to do that
ok let's go back to the patreon thing
and please for God's sakes people please
tell me there's no more money there this
is a nightmare
we're in Black Mirror we have 1740 Bible
10,000 666 seven dollars oh you
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] up alright
we're we're entering a [ __ ] up phase
okay that's where we're at we're getting
to a place where this is not good
nobody's happy about this it's not good
it's not why are you doing this this is
the Internet this is the Internet we're
here we're on the internet we're doing
it I'm trying to cancel this thing I
don't like this company I don't want
them to have any more success I'm trying
to stick a line in the sand and you
people think it's hilarious you people
juliette you're getting a mug thank you
very much and thank you for donating at
dave rubin dot-com / donate instead of
patreon they're no good they don't like
free speech they're getting 5% of your
money you people who are doing this now
to be funny we've got 24 more minutes
and then I'm pressing delete on this
freaking thing super chat 200 bucks they
want me to do a shot day by enjoyably
spent hours trying to figure out what is
going on within each of your Studios
paintings I love them I loved hearing
that so so all of my painting not not
all of them but most of the paintings so
this one right here which is a great
it's about three foot by five foot this
is an original this is an absolute
original this is done by Kaelyn Janet
you can go to Kalin Rose jan at CA y Li
and Rose Janet dot-com
she's an incredible artist who has done
some amazing stuff in my house
almost everything in my house is from
her this painting which we commish
just for just for the set obviously is I
wish I could explain it in a proper
sense if you go to her site I think she
explains the process there she knows how
much I love coffee so there's actual
coffee grinds in the painting which is
what's giving it some of the texture
over there and I wanted something that
felt a little futuristic II so that's
why you're getting those stark lines and
then I want it to feel like a little bit
less sort of like the universe and and
sort of messy and and interesting so hey
that's her in it Aaron if we can go to
the guest shot right now the regular
guest shot the painting on the other
side if we can go to that one I'm not
sure we can right now we can't go to
that one right now oh we can't right
because we moved the camera that's right
she did the one on the other side that
you normally see behind the guests head
also on her site you can see she did an
incredible it's four foot by five foot
hyperspace so the Millennium Falcon
going into hyperspace she did an
original for us she painted it over days
in our house which was a freaking crazy
labor of love she had to make a
protractor using a string and a piece of
wood she's an incredible incredible
artist and you get prints of all of
these on there I don't get a penny for
him and she's just a wonderful artist
Kalin Rose challenge calm okay you know
what you because you asked about the
paintings you gave 200 bucks all right
I'm gonna do a shot I hope you're happy
and please people stop donating at
patreon.com slash rubin report i've got
a life to live I've got to end this
thing and this nightmare this
Bandersnatch now I mean I mean it's I
mean this is what the internet is I'm in
the choose-your-own-adventure of the
Internet all right here we go all right
you want the other guy wanted me to do
this fast so here we go
here's this like we do it in Texas
there's that there's that there's that
all right love you Dave super chat I
love you
Daniel you're getting a shout out super
chat hook a brother up with the mug
please come back to Atlanta soon how did
I do that that was pretty good hook a
brother use a br oth a hook a brother I
feel like I did good on that you got it
super chat yes Orlando is the best come
back soon I would love to come back I
love I love all of those the Disney
lands and your
Universal Studios and things like that
we got him here to super jet thanks for
standing on principle Dave yeah you know
what I guess what's cool actually right
now despite the fact you people keep
giving me money on patreon even though I
asked you not to is that I'm standing up
for something that I believe in I'm
having a ton of fun right now this is
kind of fun and I'm a little drunk but
like beyond all that it's like guess
what when you stay this is what I quoted
Douglas before when you dare get in the
pool you might find out that the waters
not that cold
and that I think is the truth I think
what you guys are seeing right now I've
got people all over the world in super
chats and in kind of on patreon you
[ __ ] and and all over the place
better that are giving me money having
fun enjoying watching this and it's just
because I stood up for what I believe in
I think you can do it too like maybe the
truth does set you free who somebody
must have said that right somebody said
that Dave's serious question are there
any creators on patreon that you're
disappointed haven't joined the patreon
purged no no no the answer no everyone
has their own considerations I want to
be very clear about that someone tweeted
me about this today and I retweeted it
with comment someone said something to
the effect of oh you know sam harris
deleted his immediately and you a jordan
it's been a couple weeks and you're
tweeting about and blah blah blah and
it's like i first off i think you guys
know my feelings about sam i have
nothing but respect for him he's a good
friend and i have admiration and love
for the guy i don't know exactly what
his business considerations are so he
was able I don't know what his personal
finances are or anything or anything
else I just I I genuinely don't know for
as well as I know he deleted his on
principle I've truly nothing about
respect for that I have a different
situation here in that I have a company
that I'm running that most of the money
of the income from the company was
coming from our fan funding okay so we
have different considerations Jordan has
different considerations as well you
guys have different feelings about all
of us about where you want to spend your
hard-earned money and I do believe it is
your hard-earned money so anyone that's
on there whether Brett's staying on
there right now or Collins staying on
there sword in scales on there a whole
bunch of other people who I think are
doing doing good stuff and trying to
fight the fight the same way that I'm
trying to fight it for all I know maybe
Jordan and I leaving maybe the people at
patreon right now look I know a bunch of
the cowards and Arab
probably looking around going oh I I
hope nobody notices that I actually like
David Jordan and I'm not a programmed
robot in an NPC but but there are people
there that are probably happy that the
headache of Peterson and Reuben and
Harris is gone but I don't make my
decisions based on who might think I'm a
headache so so that's that and as I said
maybe those guys will be able to change
things from the inside you anything
anything that's a movement that matters
people do it in different ways people
did the civil rights movement in
different ways some people wanted to do
it one way some people want to do
another any anything that matters and I
truly believe we're in a battle for free
speech and if some people say you have
to stay inside the institutions and
fight some people want to fight from the
outside it's like it's all good it's all
good these people are my allies and my
friends and and I mean allies in the
best sense of it not I don't mean a lie
because they bow to me forever if there
is more money on patreon right now I'm
gonna I'm gonna well it's not gonna be
pretty people here we go I'm trying to
cancel this thing I'm going to 10,000
not 800 $95 1745 patrons please for the
love of God let those numbers be going
down there up there up again we went up
to people and we went up about 20 bucks
is that right
well I hope you're happy okay
can't afford 50 bucks because I'm saving
for psychology grad school after
discovering my interest through Jordan
any chance I could get a leftover mug if
there is one Star Wars Episode nine no
hope all right let's first up let's give
this guy a mouth I'll sign it right now
can we get any we have to figure out how
to get your email so hopefully that can
be tied into your your super chat dress
I will gladly give you a mug no problem
episode 9 no no hope so I'm glad you
asked this question because let's talk
about something else besides free speech
and the rest of it for just SEC so so so
David my husband had a little a minor
surgery over the last couple days which
on top of as busy as we've been about a
zillion things I've also had his brother
and sister-in-law here and it's mom here
and everyone's been taking care of him
and I've been trying to do the best I
can do too and and everything else he's
completely fine he's going through a
little recovery right now it's all good
but he had a little time to watch TV we
watched the prequels now I've been
saying for a couple years now that I
think years from now the prequels are
gonna be looked at very fondly very
differently than they're looked at now
is the acting bad yes is the script
stiff yes but is the story of those
prequels of what the accumulation of
power and then the flipping of power
because that's really what it's about
it's an incredible personal story of the
development of Anakin Skywalker but what
it's really about is that the Emperor
Palpatine was accumulating accumulating
accumulating power through political
processes through creating crisis's but
then at the last moment I mean this is
what Revenge of the system Sith is about
he then Akuma is enough power to get rid
of the opposition that's sort of what
we're dealing with right now
it's an incredible political story
actually what's his name Hagin Christian
is a horrible actor Natalie Portman is a
terror is absolutely terrible in this
not a big fan of hurts anymore for a
couple political reasons but I grew up
in the same town as her actually and we
went to the same high school doctor
she's a lovely woman but I'm not not a
huge fan at the moment but anyway I
think people if you look at the the
prequels and they're missing little
moments like we needed to know who Count
Dooku was a little bit more they needed
to tell us a little bit more about Sipho
dias and and why he went to the cloners
originally a couple little things but if
you remove some of that stuff the
stories are actually great force awakens
I think is a fantastic movie I think JJ
Abrams did an incredible lift of
resetting the entire thing and and last
Jedi is just horrendous it's horrendous
at every level purple-haired laura dern
why wasn't that admiral ackbar at his
last moment of glory instead you killed
them off-camera Leia there's no force in
space who the hell's Snoke now
Rey has no parents what's his name FN
two eight one seven Finn has no point in
the whole movie his whole adventure that
he goes on at the casino with the the
SJW girl
they have no point in the movie they
fail and then it should they just end up
back there with him in the end the
movies absolute crap Luke is a grumpy
old fool why at that point does he force
project himself there instead of showing
up to the final battle if he was gonna
die either way let the guy freakin and
die in a blaze of glory the whole thing
was lazy it was a resent
I think Rian Johnson basically was
resentful of Star Wars all that being
said I think JJ can fix it for episode 9
and I really I really really really
really really really really hope that he
does we shall see all right I can do it
I think I can do two more shots we got
15 minutes I think I can do two more
shots so it's gonna have to be 200 bucks
on on any format so whether it's patreon
no not patreon it cannot be patreon no
patreon people we're not doing patreon
okay I can do two more shots but you
have to do it at Dave Rubin calm slash
donate you can do it on PayPal you do it
on credit card you do it on Bitcoin I
don't care at this point please do not
do it on patreon shoutouts to Herschel
shoutouts to Ben in a mug for Jacob
Herschel Ben and Jacob I would we just
went to a shtetl in in Poland in 1860
all right there you go brother I signed
that one on the front for you that's a
rare one Jacob you're getting one on the
front
exasperated Reuben is the best Reuben
love you man okay
donating ten bucks towards having Matt
Christensen on the Reuben hoard I
probably will do that a bunch of you
have asked we will do that for sure
let's see Dave please briefly remind the
newly joined viewers how they can
support you since you're moving away
from patreon I think I've been trying to
do that dave rubin dot-com slash donate
we are building out several things we
are rebuilding my website it is going to
be completely insulated from censorship
on the video hosting front on the
platform hosting front on the
monetization front that is just one step
of getting away from patreon and these
third party people who don't live up to
the ideals that I live up to
I'm not asking the government to get
involved and that is one step on to
building a platform and then several
other steps down the road I promise you
this is just the beginning of several
markers we're gonna do something cool
here like why not write like I'm alive
you're alive let's do it okay
200 bucks no comment with donation but
time for another shot you all right here
we go
getting too old for this [ __ ] you know
what I mean here we go
patron for patreon woo and now wait a
little jelly spoons I'm going to click
refresh on the page here here we go
right now we have 147 people we're
getting ten thousand nine hundred four
dollars please if there is a God in the
universe let that number go down we went
up four dollars are you happy for
another person oh god another 200 no no
alright hold on I literally can't do
another shot right now I'm a red wine
drinker too and I'd love to do a
celebratory shot with you keep up all
the great work cheers to a beautiful
future I'll display my mug one shelf
higher than my Michael Knowles sign left
his tier mug tumbler I appreciate that
very nice stick it to that Knowles guy
that right-wing maniac that all right
maniac yeah talk about you Knowles fifty
dollars in Canadian dollars can I get a
mug I mean what is fifty Canadian
dollars worth in American six seventy
bucks I don't know what I can do for
that guy
twenty bucks let's get Dave over eleven
thousand dollars on patreon no no you're
not good you're not a good person
what's your throat on the Captain Marvel
movie I haven't tracked this thing at
all but I know what's her name's in it
brie Larson died I think she's a good
actress but is it connected to Avengers
it is right that she's gonna have some
big role in Avengers infinity war by the
way was phenomenal I have been on a lot
of planes in the last couple months I've
seen infinity war it's about 20 times
and I there it's perfect it's pretty
much perfect as a superhero movie it's
so worth donating to your telethon to
watch you load up
tequila love you and your spirit on
spirits way to upstage poke in a hockey
poke and hockey love from Jamie and
Janine poke in a hockey pokey and hockey
whatever it is that you wrote there I
feel like it was something that should
have understood and I probably just said
it wrong but I thank you for that when
the patriot and replacement is up will
it be announced on the subscribed star
site or will be a mass social media
explosion and what do you think about
the women's March controversy all right
the women's March thing I think it's
pretty obvious
look the intersectional oppression
Olympics thing it's crumbling because
they literally are like wait a minute
how can we treat Jews sure they've been
programmed in Holocaust 'add and and and
been the other in the in the law for the
longest history of anything but now
they're kind of successful over the last
50 years especially in America how
should we treat them despite the fact
there might be my brother-in-law happens
to be a brown Jew how should we treat
these people this is the essence of what
collectivism is it is the new racism
progressives or the new races racist if
you want to see something incredible by
the way look at my Twitter from about I
think three or four tweets ago David
Webb who is a conservative who happens
to be black was not doing I'm doing his
Fox Nation show I think on Thursday he
was on he was doing I it was either he
show or another show I'm actually not
sure because I such a crazy day I was
just catching these little clips he was
on with Areva Martin or even Martin
happens to be a lovely woman who's also
black she's been on my show years ago
she's a progressive they get on the show
together they're doing radio so she
doesn't know she died apparently she
didn't know who he was or anything about
him he goes on and on about something
and then she goes well you're showing
your white privilege this literally
happened today and David Webb who is a
black conservative who is a really great
guy who I've drank a lot of freaking
bourbon with that he usually pays for
that's extremely expensive he goes well
I really do you know that I'm black and
then you've got to listen to the rest of
this it's incredible because
progressivism is the new racism
understand this if you understand this
you will almost be able that is almost
the key you need to unlock almost
everything that's happening in America
the people that are peddling racism that
will want to institutionalize racism
who want white people to bow to them and
who hate Christianity and who hate
anything that's remotely traditional or
conservative and I say this as a gay Jew
you know I mean I don't say this as one
of these people that's trying to push
anyone to believe anything this is what
this thing has become and it's and it's
seriously dangerous and crazy it is 6:52
I am going to check this thing and I
don't like anyone that is gone onto this
freaking thing oh we're getting into
dangerous territory where's my mouse
what Mouse is this a mouse actually
technically is this thing about all
right 1749 people right now have donated
ten thousand nine hundred dollars a
month that it's used to be around 35,000
and a lot of you have quit and I thank
you for that
thank you for stop giving me money I
appreciate it I'm gonna hit refresh on
this and I hope that that number has
gone down and if it hasn't gone down
you've put me in some sort of Faustian
bargain here we go I don't think I
pressed it properly oh my god it went up
again didn't it what we went down we
went down $18 thank you thank you
Internet we went down $18 I've been
talking for two hours and finally after
imploring people to stop giving me over
$10,000 a month we lost $9 $18 we lost
$18 that's incredible shoutouts to
Andrew and Theresa and to Sam I
appreciate it Jim you're getting a mug
brother all right Jim you're a good man
guys would it be completely insane I'm
tempted to do this just because I cannot
believe this and but I want to get the
thumbs up from my team I'm looking
through the window here would it be
insane to extend this for a half hour
it would not be insane
I have been given the thumbs up yeah
everyone's confirming this all right
here's the deal I'm going to continue
this for a half hour I genuinely cannot
believe this is going happening
please people internet people why but
this is true this is real you freaks oh
god another 200 bucks drank Canada 50 is
37 dollars and 68 cents in the u.s. can
I get a Canadian mug oh no can I get a
kind of Canadian to get a mug that's
very different can I get a Canadian mug
that's more what is a Canadian mug how
is that different than an American mug
can a Canadian get a mug no you got to
do it monthly you can't do it on super
chat you're taking advantage of the
situation person Canadian person $50
should we be supporting Dave mugging
people good question what percentage of
your listeners do you speculate or women
so it's actually interesting so I don't
know the total answer to this because
when you do audio podcasts which
actually are audio podcasts it is
actually I think almost more popular
than the YouTube show at this point
which is bizarre because no one sees
those numbers so it's a weird thing
because you sort of judge the popularity
in terms of in terms of the YouTube
numbers last I saw are so politics in
general you talk about anything
political excuse mail now I know that
the social justice worries would love it
to have to be 50/50 and men and women
should care about the exact same things
at the exact same time no matter what
let's put that aside for just a second
generally politics skews heavily mail I
mean it's crazy it's something like
ninety ten our channel is mostly
politics obviously are mostly culture
cultural related politics let's say I
think we're at about 75 25 so I think
it's about 75 percent male 25 percent
female which is pretty evenly
distributed relative to the topics we're
talking about so it's a little hard to
say someone just donated 50 bucks on
super chat need a Reuben mug to sit next
to my left is tier mugs but you got to
go to Dave Rubin comm slash doing it
we're not doing that for super chat you
got to do it you got to do it monthly
it's just one of the things we had to do
I appreciate it thank
you alright you know what we'll do it
for that guy but I cannot we can't do it
for anyone else so if we can get that
guy's email address if we can possibly
get it
$42,000 for 42,000 Coast Guard members
still required to work did not get a
paycheck for the first time in u.s.
history that the military we're not paid
we're Europe your opinion alright so
this will be a lot to get into it this
at this moment what I would say is this
is that first off it sounds like and I
think this is a bipartisan thing which
is bizarre these days it sounds like
everyone that's furloughed right now are
not getting paid right now that works
for the government will get back pay so
that's one thing now of course that
doesn't deal with your immediate bills
now if you work for the government
shouldn't you be living in a situation
where your week to week probably not and
maybe that maybe you have to figure out
a few things for your own life but we've
all done that when I was a struggling
comic I swear in my life I remember a
day when I first up I was late on rent
and I was barely making anything and I
had I had quit several jobs and I had
done for attending and I had done
promotions and I had handed out [ __ ] on
the streets and I've done all sorts of
things and I remember and this is I was
already in my mid 20s or something like
I was way past this point and I moved in
I didn't I couldn't even afford
apartment anymore and I moved in three
guys who were great guys I didn't
Machado was Mike and Chris and an Adam
they'd even have an extra room in their
apartment they had a basically a hallway
with a cot and they let me stay there
for like I think was like fifty bucks a
month to live in New York City and I
remember one day I had no cash like I
had I literally had no cash and I did
not know what to do and I was struggling
comic and the whole thing and bla ba ba
I'm not even saying this from Crimea
River I went into Mike's room Mike is
still a good buddy of mine Mike if
you're watching this and there's a good
chance you are and I love your brother I
guess it's a good time to tell you I
took 75 cents from your change jar
choclo and that's change yaar you had a
cold chocolate that's like metal
coughing in there I took 75 cents and
maybe I took 95 cents and I went to
Zabar's we lived on the Upper West Side
I went to Zabar's which everyone that's
been to New York City knows about is a
bar
and I got a cup of coffee and I stole
change for you I felt so freakin guilty
for doing that so the struggle was real
I guess is the point of that what was
the point of that I don't really
remember okay different Marcin
seen you in the UK during Jordan
Peterson's talk hope to see you again
here soon good luck outside patron right
on brother
longtime fan just want to say you're
awesome pledging to you and Jordan on
payday ever need to design writing
worker or VA work I'm your gal much love
muah
I appreciate it wha back at ya yeah
we've got so many people offer to work
for us for free and offer to donate
skills and this or that we're trying
what I have a what I do is every time I
get an email or someone all is offering
us something or some skill set or
something I forward it to Helen who's my
assistant who's incredible actually and
has been a godsend in this operation who
we hired back in September who by the
way I think I'm allowed to say this she
over the last eight or ten years of his
life was Hugh Hefner's assistant so
that's actually pretty cool my assistant
right now is Hugh Hefner's assistant so
if I start wandering around in robes
with a lot of hot chicks around me
you'll know why in any event I forward
everything over to her and she's
compiling a list of all of these things
so we'll try to figure out a lot of this
what to do going forward all right we
got we got a half hour laughter so with
and I'm not extending it after that this
is ridiculous and I hate all of you I'm
going to press refresh here and and I
just want to say please for the love of
God we want to end this thing tonight
1749 of you for some reason have refused
to cancel your patreon accounts $10,000
eight hundred ten thousand eight hundred
ninety dollars or sitting in there here
we go yeah we lost we lost about a
thousand bucks
goodnight everybody
thank you thank you for deleting a
thousand dollars of patronage I couldn't
be happier thank you so much you're
great people you are great great people
I was so close to signing up for your
patreon recently but lol not anymore go
solo you have immense support thank you
very much let's see why didn't I get my
$25 shout out for my dave rubin monthly
pledge if I go to patreon shoutouts to
die standing you got a shout out right
there how much is a shot how much is a
double shot UK five bucks to ask that
I'll do the next shot at 200 I can't I
can't I mean what have I done now three
so far I haven't eaten all day I had I
had a little salad and and two cups of
bone broth Dave thanks for the amazing
shout out since spend some time and Paul
spent some time in Poland it was amazing
i I think Poland is actually gonna be on
the next the next tour stop so hang
tight on that all right lots going on
here
guys I see it 200 sitting in here for
drink is that a new one can I answer
another question first
is there another alright here let me
have a little water little water how
many of you watch Bandersnatch by the
way if you guys did you guys watch on
Netflix black mirror Bandersnatch where
it's a choose-your-own-adventure TV show
I actually do feel like we're kind of in
that which is which is pretty freakin
cool
Kevin Johnson were you a point guard on
the Phoenix Suns in the early 1990s
because that's pretty awesome if you
were also former mayor of Sacramento
take a sip of water Dave you're crazy
haha if you can please sign my mug
before they run out went to the website
it's properly swamped best of luck we
this is the site down is the site down
right now a broom and calm slash donate
I hope not 20 bucks you're not drunk if
you can say brewery tour brewery tour
you know it's a tough one to say I want
you to say this out loud if you're
watching this Irish wristwatch can you
say that play along with me people Irish
wristwatch that's a tough one to say and
if you can say that then you're really
not drunk
alright so apparently there's 200 bucks
in here same drink I need just a second
what are we doing here people I'm just
raising funds we're not going to do
these fundraisers we wipe ramas at least
we want I said in the last thing we're
not gonna do them all year but I think
we should probably do
maybe maybe twice a year so I promise we
won't do one two let's say June or July
or summer or something like that maybe
the last thing I do before I go off the
grid but we're just moving people over
for patreon over to Dave Rubin comm /
donate and you guys aboard it we're
we're gonna be okay we're gonna move
forward we're gonna keep building things
we're all good but we're completely
independent thanks to you guys I don't
have to join the network I don't have to
do any of these other crazy things and I
thank you for that and it's awesome it's
real this is seriously freaking real
what can I tell you
I'm monthly on PayPal but this stream is
lit as [ __ ]
AAF that's how the kids say as [ __ ]
these days by the way good to know um I
know you're somewhat at least at least
somewhat interested in comics are you
familiar with this in Sony Chu series
remember to stay hydrated
I don't know this any two people how's
my gulp sound on that every now and
again I have a drink on the show and
people say Dave you're allowed gulper so
I'm gonna just drink casually let's just
pretend I'll just pretend nobody's
watching and I'm gonna drink casually
how was that let me know in the comments
right down below okay here we go Dave
you've upstaged Elizabeth Pocahontas
Warren she drank a beer in her video I
think that was what the earlier
commenter meant to say yeah I mean but
that like that's how stupid this thing
is these people are trying to pretend to
be human I drink a beer with my husband
so I'm a real person look oh my husband
just happens to be here with my laptop
in the kitchen and he didn't know I was
gonna livestream to millions of people
it's like they're all just [ __ ]
artists and buffoons and stop paying
attention to them but at the other level
you have to be an onion because it's
your life so it's a little bit tough
because these people have unreeled we
power on your life which is a problem
late a little jelly spoons we have 25
minutes left go to Dave Rubin dot-com
session 8 I gotta get rid of some of
these freaking shirts I can't deal with
these shirts anymore I have too many of
them they're causing problems okay
they're causing marital problems I need
closet space people Dave Rubin cops -
donate 25 bucks monthly you're getting a
shirt 50 bucks monthly you're getting
the shirt you're getting the mug I'm
gonna sign it for you right now and then
we're
deleting patron I'm not extending this
thing after that I promise you were done
I know there's 200 bucks sitting there
in super chat about the about the shot
alright the next hundred if we get a
hundred after this I'll do the freaking
shot I hope you're happy let's go to the
videotape
right now we have 1745 I would say
heathens ungodly heathens who have
decided that they do not want to stop
paying us here even though I don't want
them to and I've sent several emails and
I've done live streams and tweeted about
it and the money keeps going up I think
we went down to nine dollars last time
that was nice and here we go Jesus [ __ ]
we did we just go up $1500 we just went
up $900
I can't quit you you know Dave Chris
here just wanted to let you know that
sordin scale has donated about 500 on
this stream and you're awesome and if
you need a product manager from your new
platform
Helen has my CV holla all right so Helen
does have these things I'm not making it
up we do categorize all these things
sort and scale I did not know about the
podcast before this but I do know about
it now
he's been a huge supporter in in getting
the word out about patreon I think he's
the fifth highest creator on patreon
he's planning on leaving like patreon I
don't I don't know him personally I
don't know we've traded a couple
messages I don't know what his financial
considerations are but people are trying
to do what they can and it is pretty
freaking awesome I appreciate the
support brother and let's let's just
keep trying to do what we can I kept my
patreon account simply because I wanted
to see what happens on the patreon and
and when the account we patronize is
deleted that's fair thank you for not
giving me more money I think that's what
you're saying but that's review if you
haven't deleted because you want to just
see what happens the moment I delete via
the insider thing that is happening on
patreon I do appreciate that
all right I'm giving shoutouts five
bucks above on dave rubin comp slash no
nate shirts twenty-five bucks but
monthly and and mugs on that I will do
another shot at a hundred bucks on super
chat because you people are seriously
twisted we just went up nine hundred
dollars on patreon III I don't know what
to tell you other than I can't you know
you've got to stop giving us money there
and this is not right or this is in just
I'm the Prez I'm oppressed I keep asking
people to not do something and they keep
doing it this is this is oppression is
the oppression of the Sith it is back
all right I will be in Irvine California
January 30th with the member of the IDW
at the Irvine improv you can check Dave
rubyconf lecture beds to check out that
in case he can't tell I used to be on
the radio so I've done a little bit a
little this little that over the years
all right who's jumping in on super chat
hundred bucks I'm gonna do another shot
at this point it's like let's just do it
you know you're like let's just go down
with the ship I'm gonna end up with four
billion dollars on patreon I'll be drunk
as hell I mean let's just roll with it
okay um a lot of things here
shout out to John Mike and Chrissy thank
you guys I appreciate it all right we
got it's 708 we got 22 minutes left I'm
gonna click that thing and if it's
higher I'm gonna have to really evaluate
things Aaron 1743 people have donated
ten thousand eight hundred and fifty
three dollars this is wrong this is not
good
we've gone up fourteen dollars people I
get it I get it it's all a joke so all
the joke to you people as I sit here
trying to delete this thing and you give
me your hard-earned dollars just to
stick it to the man or something like
that I mean this is actually hilarious
this is actually hair it's like I give
anyone that's given any money on their
like will clear out the account before
we delete but like legitimately
hilarious like this is not what I would
have expected okay here we go
fYI Jordan Peterson has deleted his
patreon page but BAM twenty two minutes
left people now twenty minutes left I
have I can confirm via the people in the
booth Jordan B Peterson of Canada has
deleted his patreon page all right it's
over it's gone it's done he's in
Switzerland right now he deleted it from
Switzerland okay try to grasp the
gravity of the situation
shout out to Rory thank you right now
super chat you missed Mike shoutout for
joining your site punishment is another
shot you sick twisted bastard all right
here we go
Lord may the lord have mercy on all of
us don't know what's wrong with you
people
haha alright it's good to be here
we're on patreon I'd like to announce
today that we're rebooting our patreon
page and we want to take as many
donations there as possible I feel like
that's the future of the Rubin report
joining third-party sites that don't
care about free speech and seeing what
happens let's take a role in it ice
thoughts on your comedian buddy Owen
Benjamin and him [ __ ] on everyone is
he for real or he's just part of the new
comedy routine I honestly have no idea
what's going on with him I truly can't
answer that in any in any sensible way
we got 19 minutes left I can confirm
that from Switzerland
Jordan Peterson has deleted his patreon
account I've taken I think five shots of
patron I'm 42 years old people know 42
year olds should be drinking five shots
of patron I did three shows today before
this and the Internet has screwed me by
continually donating through the patreon
account that I will be deleting in
moments and I guess it's just a sign of
the times this is what it's all about we
who live in the Internet on this tube
this YouTube we're but humble servants
to you people but but really this is
like a choose-your-own-adventure
you watching this right now are
controlling my destiny it's it's
extremely bizarre also I just realized
what's very bizarre it's only seven 12
in the evening here hey I haven't a
dinner but rebut be in 18 minutes when I
end this thing after I click delete I'm
gonna be drunk
I have several employees and family
members here none of them we're gonna be
drunk is anyone drunk in there not yet
not yet all right they're not drunk
people very bizarre
okay subscribe 425 but change it to 50
and didn't get another email will I
still be able to get a mug keep up the
good work yeah we'll make sure we'll see
to your name twice in there Helen can
you make sure we take care of that for
sure we will deal with that all right
ask me anything people ask me anything
we are deleting patreon all right let's
look here we go let's do it right now we
have one thousand seven hundred and
forty-four patrons
despite at least five emails despites
three live streams despite at least 20
tweets Instagram posts everything please
stop giving me money delete your patreon
account I don't want anything to do with
you people despite all of that we still
have 1700 people left and we have ten
thousand nine hundred fifty seven
dollars here we go what do we I think we
went up we went down almost $900 that's
what I'm talking about people purged the
money let's get it out of patreon they
don't want our money they've got Silicon
Valley money they've got VC money they
don't need our money
I love the fact that people at patreon
are watching this right now like that's
actually pretty hilarious that's the
other thing about the Internet the
Internet is so stupid these days that
you have Silicon Valley people who these
people all these social justice warriors
or more so you have most of them are
libertarians actually I mean the secret
of Silicon Valley is that most of these
people are libertarians because they
believe that they have ideas to create
and that that would give you a very
Liberty minded view of the world
they've become hostages to this SJW
thing and because of that then there are
around a bunch of people who they
actually don't like and I'm talking to
all of you Silicon Valley people that I
know are watching this right now they
become hostages to all of these people
and then they're all they're all just a
bunch of sort of cowards right and then
with all the soy and everything else
there they can't really stand up for
themselves so what happens is it just
becomes this self-fulfilling prophecy
that no one will stand up for what they
believe in so I have no doubt that there
are plenty of people at patreon that
completely support what I'm doing here
and and whatever but it's like the fact
things
think about this so I joined patreon in
it was either June or May I think was
June of 2016
we've been on there for two and a half
plus years we were basically making
about 30 grand a month there that funded
this whole basically funded this entire
company so you'd have to do the math on
that two and a half years of 30 grand a
month can someone do the math on that
300 600 that's almost a million bucks
over the course of three years to fund a
company now that sounds like a lot of
money but when you're fronting a company
and paying a lot of people it's not a
ton of money but think about like Ivan
I've put a lot of money into this
company Santa has put a lot of money
into this company Jordan Peterson put a
lot of money in this company the fact
that nobody reached out to us you'd
think that some low-level nobody would
would reach out and say guys we're
having this little issue here but that's
what that's what's become the problem
with these companies now interestingly I
know that the lefties will say ah
because you don't want regulation of
these companies and you think they can
do whatever they want to do yes I do
think they can do whatever they want to
do they can do whatever they want to do
and I can do whatever I want to do
freedom is messy but freedom is good
shout out to Ethan thank you very much
$69 curious number I think you're onto
something with this whole pay me and
I'll take a shot fundraising I might try
it and see if it works when you're not
famous oh well my famous I guess I'm
famous it's weird that that's also a
weird thing because I'm not an odd level
of Fame where like clearly I guess I'm
famous at some level but like I go to
Whole Foods or I cook like anywhere like
I go to like the bowling alley or like
wherever it is that I go or I go to like
Petco like people recognize you or often
I'll see people looking at me and I'm
like they'd like me I don't know if they
or do they think I'm a white supremacist
so most of my day is wandering around
strange stores picking up food from my
dog going ah do they think I'm a white
supremacist which think I'm stupid this
thing oh the whole thing has become next
time you take a shot I'll make a set
make a sound like Anderson Cooper and
I'll donate $100 all right that's funny
that's funny that might be the funniest
thing that's happened this whole time so
if nobody watched CNN on New Year's Eve
like what kind of life do you have that
you'd watch CNN on New Year's Eve but on
but you might have watched a clip of it
on Twitter and I saw a five-second clip
him in an econ and it's a kubernetes
code they're taking shots and it's like
that's the one night of the year that
the CN n people like to get to act like
humans but they can't really act like
humans because they've spent a year not
acting like a human so how can they act
like a human on one night that's a tough
gig but so Anderson take a shot it's
like oh my god it's bad so all right you
know what here's I'll do 500 bucks I
will do an Anderson Cooper impression
while taking a shot but it's got to be
500 on I'm sorry the money's going up on
patreon despite the fact that I wanted
to go down so here
the rubber meets the road people I will
do an impression of Anderson Cooper hey
Dave keep up the good work I came to
America to be around people like you
instead I found free speech police
hopefully people like you helped turn
things around awesome I'd love to know
where you're from
can you do something that we can figure
out where this person is from I love
that story
that's the only thing when I go into a
burrs and cabs in all these places that
I go to whether it's in the States or
not it's like everyone that I've met
it's like everyone loves to be in the
West they love to be in Canada they love
to be in the UK they love to be in
America it ain't that bad how much for a
six-shot you made it you donated $5 and
69 cents
another interesting number I remember
the time before you had a patreon right
after the ad pocalypse it won't be that
bad we're going to be all right all
right Jesse you're getting a mug brother
or sister Jesse could be a guy could be
a girl but who am i to assign a gender
to Jesse you know and again Jesse
whatever gender you are I just want you
to know I think you're a great gender
you know like you're really a great guy
or gal you know Jesse great gal great
guy or gal okay here we go we got 13
minutes left by the way my phone is
exploding right now I don't want to show
the names of the people uh-huh my phone
is exploiting which either means that
I've ruined my career tonight or we got
some good [ __ ] going on I suspect it to
the latter but you never know here we go
we're gonna hit refresh we have one
thousand four hundred forty-four people
we've got eleven
minutes remaining please if there is a
Lord in the universe if any of this
means anything let the number 10,000 and
79 go down we went up $900 all right you
know what I love there is a set of
anonymous Twitter accounts that are run
by journalists there's about there's
about 10 influential lefty anonymous
accounts on Twitter that are run by
journalists and they think they're
really clever and I know they're
watching this waiting for me to say
anything off script or whatever even
though there's no script here they're
waiting for me to just say anything
that's anything and what they do is
they're anonymous Twitter they're
journalists or friends of journalists
and what they do is they wait to clip
one thing and then they magically get
HuffPo or BuzzFeed or Vox which is the
worst or any of these things to quote
what I say and say Reuben was drunk and
Motorola said of this and it's like I
know they're just sitting there watching
this and they couldn't get they couldn't
get anyone to give them a buck and I'm
literally asking people you know give me
money right here we go I can afford a
couple of months at 50 right now hope
that gets me a cool sign mug jesse is
with Jesse without the I Ismael now stop
flirting with me all right Jesse welcome
back all right so Jesse's gonna get the
mug and you're right so it was Jes se
which I assumed was a male but these
days with the way gender is so fluid and
the way just because you have a penis
you might be uh you know you could be a
woman you you could be a decepticon
whatever it is Sith Lord doesn't matter
the point is you know we're just doing
the best we can
ladles and jelly spoons we have we have
nine minutes left we went up
the best part of this is so we really
had the last couple days here really
have been insane so David had surgery as
I mentioned before so David's not even
part of this dave is the executive
producer of the show who has run if
anything I do looks remotely
professional or anything maybe maybe not
today but generally speaking David has
done this this is this is him he is he
he learned this from scratch and has
become I I would say the best executive
producer probably in the business and he
he could not work these last couple of
days cuz he had it was it was a minor
sinus related surgery by like he was
knocked out on pain meds and all sorts
of stuff the last couple days so we are
my whole team is completely stepped up
we brought in some other people on my
brother and sister-in-law have helped
and a whole bunch of people and the fact
that we here we are this morning I said
to David I was like I hope with that by
the end of this like I don't know how to
get to these patreon people like it's
actually incredible and it's a little
sign of the times or something that a
certain amount people just donate to
things and forget about it and I mean
that I don't mean that judging them in a
negative way I mean that is like it's
actually kind of cool it's like
someone's got a couple bucks and it's
like you follow you you give to
something you believe in anything you
just forget about it's like what a what
a luxury that is what a great thing that
is but I was like at the end of this
like it would be so cool if the entire
livestream two hours we could watch this
number drop drop drop drop drop drop
drop drop and we have not had that
happened alright a hundred fifty bucks I
think what you're doing is great and I
fully support your willingness to take a
stand and have the conversations nobody
else will have thank you you know what
you didn't even ask me to take a shot
but I'm feeling the flow it's 723 this
is patron ladles and jelly spoons ladles
and jelly spoons I want to give a shout
out I hope my buddy so when I did stand
up in New York for 12 years and I hope
you guys will come out and see me do
stand-up in the future because people
don't know that part of me until they
see it and then people like holy [ __ ]
you're actually good at this but which
is actually more of a fun thing because
people don't even come to the show and
they don't even know what to expect but
there were two comics who I knew that
were great that I'm gonna give a public
shout out to now that I don't even know
that you can find anything about
online the two best comics that I ever
knew in 12 years of stand up in New York
where Bob jorgens and Mike singer and I
don't know that you can find anything
about them Bob's an actor now so I hope
you can at least find out about him I
don't know what happened to Mike but Bob
used to always get on stage and if he
was really struggling he'd ham it up and
go come on
ladles and jelly spoons and I just
thought it was the funniest thing so
here we go in honor of Bob and the
old-timers why why you're not I look
forward to The Huffington Post piece on
this will you drink the whole bottle if
the never goes down to zero I mean that
would genuinely be the end of my life
which is sort of how this all should end
right like it should all end on a live
stream yeah all right I hear you're new
it's it's 7:24 I'm gonna do one check
right now and then at exactly 7:30 we're
deleting this [ __ ]
regardless of what you sons of [ __ ]
have done here we go it's 7:25 I'm
clicking refresh we're taking it's taken
some time there was no change it did not
change thank you that's all I ask
it doesn't have to go down although I'd
like it to go down but we prefer not to
go all right so that's we're right
that's the official number Aaron can you
throw back to that thing all right so
this is the final official number I have
1740 for patrons that are donating ten
thousand nine hundred eighty-seven
dollars a month I am will come back here
protect I am a hundred percent joking
aside and completely acknowledging the
the humor and the troll ish nature of
the people of who have donated last hour
I'm completely appreciative of all the
people that have done this and it's sort
of hilarious and many of them maybe will
see this video in a week or something
people have lives due so I'm completely
appreciative of anyone that's been part
of this thing and a shout out to Patrick
and to Mike right now
so I'm appreciative of all of that we're
gonna donate this thing in five minutes
and I so let me get serious for just a
moment and then and then we're gonna
leave this thing here you know what I'll
do these two quick questions
come on please give Anderson Cooper come
on please give an the Anderson Cooper
impression I was supposed to use the
hundred dollars and subscribe to
subscribe to ben shapiro but here i am
and that's your pyro by the way it's his
birthday today and because he would not
bake me a gay cake I did not get send
him a cake I wanted to send them a
cupcake but you know if you're not gonna
bake me a gay cake for my gay wedding
I'm not gonna send you a birthday cake
so you get nothing
Shapiro's I left patreon as I support
the First Amendment and they silenced
quite a few people how do i attain a mug
you can get a mug if you go to Dave
Rubin calm slash donate and you donate
$50 a month and you can cancel whenever
you want but if you donate $50 a month
to start we'll send you a mug I
shouldn't have said that because you you
know we want you to obviously keep doing
anything but it is what it is ladies and
gentlemen we have three minutes left
love drunk Dave can't believe you didn't
get sick on camera you're a trooper old
school you know what I'm saying
old school all right we got two minutes
left I just want to say really this has
been a pleasure there's a huge part of
me that wants to keep this going right
now but I know I probably should not and
I know that my my dedicated staff has
lives
some of them might want to get laid
tonight or do whatever they do in their
own lives so for me to sit here and
continue this insanity would be would be
selfish and I don't want to do that so
I've got about two minutes left more
than anything else I genuinely want to
thank you guys anyone that forget anyone
that's donated knew for a second for any
of you that had donated over the last
two and a half years the day that we
started the patreon thing and I and I
quit my job at aura TV and and my
executive producer and my director quit
with me on a lark it truly was a lark we
did not know what was gonna happen and I
said to them the night before I said I
if I may have screwed up all of our
lives like I had worked so hard to get
something and I quit a network so that
we could do something
we didn't know what was gonna happen in
the next morning within within a half
hour we knew we were gonna be okay we've
been okay every ever since then and
there's been ups there's been downs the
twists and turns that that come along
the way but I've really I truly I have
genuinely tried to do the best thing
that I could along the road I've made
mistakes I'm not perfect I thought open
to the same criticism that everyone else
is open to but I promise you guys this
is just the beginning it's just the
beginning again which is weird that
there's something about life in that at
the beginning can keep happening if you
keep doing something real I don't know
what that is
but I actually think it is something and
I'll keep trying to do it the best I can
so I thank you guys for that let's see
I will ask I will answer one more
question and then at 7:29 and we're
gonna delete this [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
tag-team wrestling match tag-team
wrestling match ben shapiro and jordan
peterson verse Dave Rubin and Eric
Weinstein who would win I want to think
this one through and I love the fact
that this is the last thing that I'm
gonna do before I cancel this thing and
a shout out to Michael real quick
Shapiro and Peterson now - Shapiro
Shapiro small but she Pierrot fast he'll
get you now Peterson's got that long
reach and he's got quick hands so you
got quick hands and you got somebody
quick so there's a lot of speed Dave
Rubin and Eric Weinstein I'll do Reuben
last that guy's good Weinstein now he
can think it through he can think of
he's got big hair so he could use his
hair as a weapon so now you're looking
at a hair weapon situation I could also
envision a situation where Eric's just
gonna plow through a Weinstein you know
what I mean like they're gonna get
face-to-face and and Shapiro is gonna be
moving fast but Eric's just gonna plow
through now you got Ruben you know he's
the most fit of the
ladies and gentlemen I'm gonna delete
patreon right now I'm gonna leave that
decision of that question which is an
extremely important question which is
about the Battle of ideas and they were
aggressive left and all of it I'm gonna
leave that I'm gonna set that down and
I'm gonna delete patreon my phone is
exploding my phone is on fire I can't
show you all this
my phone is actually melting through the
table right now I have a time bomb
sitting with me it's time to do Lea
patreon in case it's not clear thank you
guys thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you whether you whether you
donate it on patreon in the past whether
you donate now and even if you didn't
donate if you I don't care truly we're
gonna be okay and if you were any part
of this part of the silliness that we've
done for the last two and a half hours
this is as good as it gets this really
is as good as you get as far as anything
I know on this universe this is as good
as it gets so I'm gonna hit refresh on
this thing one more time and then you're
gonna watch me delete this so here we go
so right now after two and a half hours
we have more money than we started with
and I think more patrons may know no
maybe we lost patrons but we have more
money but here we go I'm refreshing okay
so we did actually go down so IO and
throw to me one more time okay so we did
actually go down so thank you I don't
know what happened here and I don't know
why I guess all of these people like it
just is what it is it is what it is it's
all good guys thank you
really really I wish I could say this in
a way that could possibly be more
genuinely felt and I'm possibly saying
it right now we're genuinely genuinely
genuinely thank you but it's all I can
say and this is just the beginning so
now I'm going to click delete
so I think there's a delete here
somewhere so I'm gonna click settings
we're doing it live [ __ ] it we're doing
it live
I'm clicking account look now I may have
to move here for it just sayin
physically because I got a scroll I know
there's a way to scroll without doing it
the way I do it old-school but I do it
old-school disable my account
there we go guys this is it careful this
will permanently disable your account
you won't be able to log in again and
after you do this oh wait a minute wait
a minute actually I should do one thing
just to be clear in case that's actually
true I don't want them stealing the
money that you guys donated even though
I didn't want you to donate money so
let's do it let's just knock that out
real quick pay out preferences so in the
course of the last two and a half hours
where I've tried to lose money on this
thing
you guys donated one thousand four
hundred fifty two dollars and 89 cents
so thank you you freaks so we're gonna
send the Hat oops don't look at that
that's my old gmail don't want to see
that okay all right so I have nothing in
my patreon right now and now I'm gonna
click settings please don't email me I
have you know other things going on
okay so settings settings all right all
right settle down look by quick messages
no we don't want to see that okay ignore
that sorry Lord settings
no quick accounts what to the right
account on the left
to the right to the right oh god it's
not a song doesn't Beyonce do that
oh that's to the left what Oh count
there we go all right all right here we
go
this is it ladies and gentlemen drum
roll please oh god please enter your
password wait
hey I don't know the password dude
someone's gonna get the password all
right Aaron please come back to camera
one I'm gonna mosey on in I don't know
the password
it could be anything
4 to 9 1 6 8 4 ABCD of ye some
combination thereof
no idea I guess I'll in the moment we're
looking for the password and we have it
in a very secure play oh I've got a team
member nobody did it what are you stupid
you can't say a lot what that was
literally the dumbest thing that has
ever happened in the history of the
internet you gotta write it down you
idiot can you tell me the password that
was that was that was that was the
beautiful ending to this whole thing all
right now I'm gonna have to go back to
this thing we got the password this is
true lunacy I guess I could do another
shot all I'm waiting
hmm oh it's being written down all right
I'm being handed the piece of paper
off-camera thank you I've been handed
the paper damn that's the password
well [ __ ] all right here we go enter
password submit Oh password okay here's
what I'm gonna do for a second I'm just
gonna get in front of the camera so I
can just knock this thing out so here we
go
okay I have placed the password in the
patreon I'm deleting and I remember guys
I have about ten thousand bucks a month
that I could just repeat and it clearly
wouldn't go anywhere and I keep getting
this money
Zippity damn do here we go submit to
keep your ass calm for God's sake
there's my email address again my
private one to keep your account safe
we've sent you an email at bla bla bla
with the link to disable your account
okay hold that thought guys this is
we've entered we've entered true
something another errand maybe you want
to go to the other camera is my head
even in the camera
alright everybody how are you Dave Rubin
trying to delete my patreon account okay
okay
we're sorry we're all right errand here
we go we're sorry to see you go you're
receiving this email because you've
requested to disable your account in
account settings if you didn't request
this please contact patreon support to
ensure the security of their account I
would email them and ask them their
thoughts about freedom of speech but
it's a little late for that if you do
want to disable your account simply
click on the disable my account button
below your account will be permanently
disabled and you won't be able to log
into your patron account using this user
name and password associated with the
account thanks for checking out patreon
you will be missed in five four three
two oh for God's sakes there's another
freaking button
are you sure you want to disable your
patreon account this action cannot be
rarest let's keep it going for six more
hours No here we go oh you've got to be
[ __ ] kidding me
there was a problem disabling your
account you were disabled link may have
expired please visit your account
settings and try unbelievable
unbelievabl on you got to be kidding me
you got to be kidding me
visit your account settings alright hang
tight people go to account settings
let's try that again you've got to be
kidding me
disable my account
I'm putting the password in again Jesus
Christ
hold on hold on
we sent your email all right well now
congratulations you all have my private
emails it
that's wonderful we'll be changing that
one soon enough confirmation needed got
it zero minutes ago we're sorry to see
you go disable my account
yes disable my account Aaron come back
to the one shot I'll be on patreon
forever all right I don't know what the
hell is going on here I promise you I
will delete this [ __ ] thing whenever
I can
this is this is actually a perfect
ending to this whole story right like
this is the way these companies operate
if I email this these people tomorrow
they would not respond to me I'd have to
publicly shame them on Twitter like I do
with YouTube all the time I wouldn't be
able to get to in touch with the person
all of these stupid things all right
let's not worry about it I think you
guys got the point I mean what what a
ridiculously anticlimactic yet totally
fitting ending to all of this I would
try one more time but I think you guys
we illustrated the point here so is what
it is so on that moat on that note
I genuinely have nothing but thanks for
you guys that's it I got nothing but
thanks thank you guys thank you for my
team that that helped me make this whole
thing happen today and and since we
started this whole operation I thank
everybody that was part of this
craziness today whether it was on super
chat or patreon or wherever it was yeah
I got a I got a bottle of patron and a
patreon account I can't get rid of and
therein lies an incredible story which
will probably make it into my book that
I'm writing right now so you guys saw it
happen live so so genuinely thank you
and wait a minute we were late Jordan
deleted his account so Jordan was able
to delete his account and I can't delete
my account yeah all right all right I'm
deleting this account please never come
back to the patreon.com slash Reuben
record page fight for what you believe
in even if it's not the things that I
believe in but fight for them honestly
and forthrightly forthrightly and and
decently and understand that you're
supposed to live in a country with
people that disagree with you we'll keep
having these conversations this really
is just the beginning George and I are
gonna build something great there's all
sorts of steps and all along the road to
make this happen I think you got the
point already and and thank you and I
have to pee goodnight
[Music]